what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
kitchen back again with another podcast
good evening and hi and welcome to
Auntie Jenny's video channel to Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you'd like not just
if you're saying generation and that
likes the same things that you do go in
there having fun then get out okay okay
then then get out then get out faster
Esther then get out I'm not here to get
canceled today most men want a woman
that has some degree of femininity where
they feel like they're taking care of
taking care of I'm a lady like I'm
submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say well I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened to society that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
now he's
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
uh before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and let's get started
um a couple of announcements before I
start the show the first guys if you
have anything you want to say um this
show any questions you want to ask send
a super chat a blessing what are we
reading um what's the minimum number
today I'll be nice five five dollars
five dollars today yeah all right we're
gonna be reading a lot of supers all
right over five dollars we will read
them we're gonna be taking breaks
throughout the show I'm to do the super
chats blessing is going to remind me
because I'm trying to take more breaks
and do it a little bit more often
um so Sun Super Chat so they will be all
be read over five dollars
um also guys
um Saturday is our last show before
blessing and I go to the U.S
um so we're going to the U.S for about
three weeks when we're going to a lot of
different cities so one if you're
interested in meeting us we're doing
meetups along the way sign up for our
Google form that should be in the live
chat
um also
um yeah so Saturday we're not gonna do
shows for like three weeks but we are
gonna have a lot of like one-on-one
interviews in the US behind the scenes
content Vlog um in the time being and
also King riches is gonna have shows
five days a week so if you guys are
missing the live show just go to King
Rich's channel the link to that is in
the description
um okay guys so we have four membership
tiers you already know first tier lets
you be a part of the live chat tonight
blessing um how many likes to open up
the live chat one thousand a thousand
likes and we will open up the live chat
tonight
um also second tier guys you get to be a
part of our Discord and our behind the
scenes Vlogs third tier you get to
connect with me on social media and
fourth tier you get to have a one-on-one
call with me once a month
um if you guys want to know how to get a
million subscribers in a year um Step Up
Your production whatever you're looking
to learn um sign up for that tier
um also guys Instagram follow my
Instagram they took away my first one um
so follow my new one just probably
things one
also subscribe to Wife School we're
going to do a new fashion episode coming
out soon because I've been getting some
complaints about my last one
um also go follow our new Talent
channels we have three Talent channels
on King Richie's Auntie Jenny and the
fresh prince of Zamunda so make sure you
go subscribe to all three um I think um
Amiri is actually going to be reacting
in the back during the show so if you
guys need to you know take a break
during super chats or something he is
reacting now
um also guys
um oh follow our animation Channel if
you if you liked the little animation
that they did in the intro
um we do have a full-on animation
Channel just pearly animations
um okay yeah I think that's all of our
announcements to start right I'm not
missing anything blessing no no okay oh
welcome to the show um everyone to start
say your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself
starting here and then go around and
then we can do second row okay hello my
name is Helene I'm 47 years old uh I'm
dating somebody and a fun fact about me
is that I love to dance with like
Reckless abandon
hey guys my name's Royal I'm 32 years
old I am single by choice and a fun fact
about me is that I am a spiritual
Alchemist and I love to give advice
um and one day I would like to have my
own advice talk show So when you say
single by choice what does that mean it
means everyone wants me but you know I'm
just trying to remember if you found the
perfect guy today had everything you
wanted you would just say no no
absolutely not I'm looking for my soul
mate okay so so it's not really a choice
right because you just haven't got you
don't see this I haven't found the guy
yet yeah yeah but I I just never
understand like when I hear sing about
your house I'm like so you found the
perfect guy you wouldn't the thing is I
could be with someone but I just choose
not to that's why I feel like single by
choice okay because the guys you want
you that want you you don't wanna yeah
okay okay go ahead my name is Penelope I
am empowering the overweight to overcome
and that's like my mission that's
something I'm really passionate about
and I'm in a long-term monogamous
relationship
hello
hello everyone my name is yusra I'm 26
years old and well let's say I'm single
and fun fact about me
um
I speak four languages and I change
personality uh whenever I change I
switch the language you change your
personality the tenacity of my
personality
like girl you got multiple personalities
I don't think you should be saying that
but the tone changes okay your tone your
tone yeah okay
um
many rooms I'm 33 definitely in a
relationship and
um fun fact about me is I ain't fun
thank you uh I'm smokes I'm 35
um I'm dating someone at the moment and
I don't know fun fact about me
I don't know I feel like I can see I
have a I have a vision ahead of me five
years but that's just in my head I don't
know if it's true can you can you see my
future five minutes
I was just hoping I could be like a part
of it I don't know no not yet not yet
maybe if I get to know y'all oh I didn't
mean like that it's not like the future
scene sorry I'm glad I'm Ted I'm 40 uh
six I think and you forget I do yeah it
keeps on happening every year it changes
um I'm I I'm seeing somebody and fun
fact I got in trouble from last time and
I didn't say I was seeing somebody
oh okay so now you're clear
you wanna say anything to her anything
else no no no okay God
um hi guys I'm Edina I'm 30. I'm dating
and uh fun fact I'm a Hungarian living
in London and I used to be an English
teacher in South America oh wow oh cool
go ahead my name is mahezy I'm 29 years
old I'm single and fun fact uh
I'm a spiritual Revolution revolutionary
slash dancer I don't know if you know
what that is but you know we can dive
into that
yeah tell me
spiritual Revolution list um first okay
I'm very much connected to my spiritual
journey I understand a lot of
traditional and Indigenous indigenous
ways that you know needs to be preserved
and I'm like
part of my life is dedicated to kind of
you know restoring that knowledge
yourself and helping other people
connect back to their you know
cultural history that's like valuable
okay yeah yeah and then I'm a dancer
means I'm a dancer okay
how do you I'm a little confused I don't
really know what you just said so you
so how would I like connect to my
cultural history well I think it's
important to just look at where you are
now and understand what history has
happened it's Humanity first and then
where do you fit in in terms of like
your lineage your bloodline I'm Irish
you're Irish see no you can connect back
to us and it's history oh okay and you
know so I'd like look it up that's how I
would do it I mean yeah the internet's
free chat GPS free I was just wondering
um okay so uh today
um we're gonna talk about where have all
the good woman gone so one thing I
always hear is where I have all the good
men gone right in society
um however I just started looking up
some stats okay one in three women have
an STD one in three women have had an
abortion 38 of kids are born into single
parent homes the average age of first
child is 26 which is before the average
age of first marriage which is 30.
um 45 of marriages end in divorce the
average number of partners for a woman
is between four and eight and when women
get below above five Partners their
chance of a happy marriage goes from 80
to 20 depends on the study plus or minus
um and if men get picked the wrong woman
they can be financially ruined and their
kids can be taken from them and on top
of that 70 of women
um 60 70 of women are overweight in the
U.S
um so um the question is how does a guy
identify a good woman
and what percent of women do you think
are good women
really good question how does a guy
identify a good woman I think mostly
it's looks but that's not how they do it
but I think it's about it it's about a
Vibe actually it's about an energy and
it's about respect
if a woman you know can really show this
man that she respects him okay but in
the beginning that's challenging because
you know you're on a first date I think
the first indication is usually looks
what was the second question bro what
percent of women do you think are good
women ooh in this day and age yes I
think women are so confused
it's really hard to say I would say good
woman what do you mean by that what I
mean by that I think a good woman is
probably less than 10 these days okay I
think a good woman is a healed woman so
I feel like the reason why there's not
much good women out there is because no
one really knows how to heal and recover
from their past relationships and
traumas and so they bring those women
not be like broken to begin with yeah
100 yeah yeah yeah yeah and so I feel
like they found ways to heal and they've
like taken time out to isolate
themselves and I feel like maybe then
they will be able to move forward and
find the right partner for the right
reasons and I feel like
um why the percentage may be so low is
because no one's really willing to do
the hard doc Shadow work what do you
mean Shadow because whenever I hear like
this no no offense like the shadow work
the healing I always hear like nothing
yeah like never like real concrete steps
of like so if you're a woman you're
trying to improve what do you what do
you do so you're trying to select your
ego you know the dark side of you beside
that you don't show anyone but it can
come out so you're trying to like kind
of tame that and work on your
insecurities and all the things that you
don't want people to see okay and so you
can how do you how do you work on them
so I mean for me personally I write down
I I Journal stuff so I write things down
my fears or things I don't like about
myself or that I want to change or that
I feel I'm ex I'm expression maybe in
the wrong way and so I try and like find
ways to fix that and just you know work
so how are you like held you know like
if I want to lose weight you go to a
personal trainer and they say like good
bad like how do you hold yourself
accountable to do it doing research
finding a routine making sure that
you're consistently keeping up with
things and maintaining that process
yeah like this just kind of sounds like
nothing to me yeah okay so I'm just I'm
sorry
no no but like when I whenever I hear
girls like talk about this it just
sounds like okay I write in my journal
um I and I Google things online and I
try to be better but there's no like
accountability like anyone keeping you
in check to like show that you are
getting better I think most people
um don't have anyone to keep them in
check when there's a will there's a way
if you really want to change then you
will make sure that you get that [__]
done like so so if you're talking to a
guy and he says like okay you you said I
was broken before I'm Healed now like
what steps would you show them that I am
now healed
um you're able to be more compassionate
and less judgmental and more open and
vulnerable okay so how could you prove
that you are just by being just by being
that I mean I feel like time will tell
okay you know okay because like I was
just thinking like if you want to
concrete steps it's like married mentors
maybe a male therapist like that sort of
thing I just never hear whenever I hear
women's self-improvement it's always
like be more confident write in a
journal and Google things no no fat like
respectfully I just I just don't
understand but you know what's crazy
I've tried personally I've tried therapy
and I've and the first time I tried it I
walked out in an anger and rage that I
was like human and the second time I
told her it's not gonna work I don't
think you can fix my problems I agree
with you I've done the therapist before
and I just thought therapy was like
stupid for the most part and now I'm in
school for psychology and I see the
women that are therapists and they're
nuts I would not go to therapy yeah I
feel like they don't care they're just
getting paid to do what they need to do
they don't give a [__] so yeah yeah but
but I do think there are some male
therapists that are helpful mostly like
male
um what do you think about that
um I've never had a male therapist and I
wouldn't go to a male therapist because
I need to I need to connect with a woman
that's like you know what I mean like
women like you no that's broken like me
not necessarily but I feel like women
connect easier no I think I think women
looked at comfort and men look to solve
problems and that's why I don't think
therapy works when they're women most of
the time there's exceptions because like
men like women are just gonna comfort
you they're gonna tell you what you want
to hear and then we'll tell you how to
fix it but the problem is like women we
never want to fix it like actually fix
it it's interesting yeah it's true I had
a male therapist actually before I had a
therapist for eight years I'm not in
therapy anymore but the first four years
was it was a woman in the last four
years of man and I'm not in therapy
anymore and I'm like I'm good now but
that's because it was a man not a woman
because when I was a woman they would
just sit there and soak in all my issues
and all the problems and there was never
a solve or a solution no one was trying
to help me and then trauma what's her
like and they call everything trauma
everything you know everything abuse or
trauma I'm like what the [__] what do
you mean I don't believe in trauma I
don't believe in trauma either it's a
bunch of yes it's just so that
psychologists can make money off yeah
well I do I do believe in like War
trauma like from War what do you mean
like I think if a guy goes to war and
sees some like sees things that's real
trauma but the way we use it today my
ex-boyfriend cheated on me my it's just
everything's strong everything but can I
say something don't you think there's
something called unhealed baggage that
we'd be carrying with our because we
haven't overcome how we felt in the last
relationship you should just get over it
okay
yeah yeah I think that we should quit
whining our great grandmothers had to
deal with like they used to have plagues
and [__] getting cheated on like this is
just the example I'm using but most of
modern day problems are really nothing
compared to like 100 200 years ago you
could get the plague and like die you
know that'd be traumatic being afraid
you know and you're right you know what
because I feel like personally I've been
through so much I haven't had real
therapy and I'm I'm strong I'm I'm still
going you know what I mean I don't
really it's not affecting me maybe it is
in a way but it's not in intervening in
my life yeah strongly the reveling in
the story is what a lot of the women
therapists were using Penelope is my
daughter and they were um you know
really listening to your story and and
giving a lot of emphasis to it like you
were really overweight and the
therapists were like no no don't don't
talk about it don't don't don't try to
help her lose weight and I'm like what
do you mean like we've got to fix this
problem like what's the plan it was so
frustrating oh so they wouldn't try to
solve like how big were you I was 300
pounds
300 pounds you look great
foreign
how did your life change from going from
300 pounds to I don't know what you are
now but clearly not so I lost 130 pounds
actually wow and you're tall too yes
what are you six two no five nine and a
half oh [__] you look you look tall as
hot okay
um but basically I was you know I think
part of the problem was because I was in
therapy for so long and I nobody told me
in therapy that there was anything wrong
with me and I had depression I had
anxiety I had suicidal thoughts and I
was not I didn't have a good
relationship with my father at the time
and nobody was saying oh you need to
lose the weight your life will be better
if you just do that nobody they tried to
give me medication they tried to give me
pills they tried to put me in more
therapy and it was until one day I
looked in there and I'm like I don't
want to be like this anymore I don't
want to feel like this anymore and to be
honest the body positivity movement
crushed my soul and told me oh you
should be you know you're beautiful no
matter what size you are you're
beautiful no matter you know how much
you weigh you're beautiful no matter
what you eat you can eat anything you
want and you're gorgeous go girl and I
and I thought it was okay wow I thought
it was okay because no one said anything
and I could be sitting here if 300
pounds right now if I didn't make the
decision to say Penelope you need to get
your butt off the couch and work out fix
your diet fix your mental health fix
everything and now I'm perfectly fine no
meds just naturally all natural what do
you do you think that contributes to 70
of women being overweight in the U.S
completely I completely think that
yeah go ahead no I just think that I
think that the fact that people are
obese and that they make all these
excuses for oh I'm obvious because of
the summer because you can lose weight
no matter what anyone can lose weight
it's just about finding the right way to
do it and what do you think of the women
that say we need like representation and
magazines
um we need fat chicks on the cover
Victoria's Secret fashion show it
proposes me so it repulses me to see
that because you've been there it does
because I've been there and not only
that but you are showing thousands and
millions of women in the world that it
is one okay to be unhealthy too okay to
be slowly killing yourself and three
okay to go outside and dress
provocatively with your rolls out
I was a plus-sized model right in the
90s you were a plus-sized mom in the 90s
yeah is there anything wrong with a
little plus-sized girl yeah because what
about the people that actually what
about the people that actually can't
lose weight
but what about people that actually but
they mentally can't so for the rest of
their life they're going to be that same
size they need some they need some
empowerment because otherwise they could
you know
do you go to um a basketball game and
look to see like an NBA game all right
what do you guys have since football
right football here you go to a football
game here and you try to see average
football players
average like below average football
players play football here when you go
to a professional game do we see them no
do you do you go there to see that oh uh
well no so then right on the cover of
magazines which is supposed to be the
epitome of beauty do we have below
average women on it right
like why like why is that why do we need
that
I I feel ashamed I don't like it I don't
want to see it I think you're right
about the fact that they're doing it too
because you know if you want to talk
about the health system and the way the
world's set up they don't want people to
come out of a BCE right so they're going
to make it look like it's okay they
don't want you to so so why wouldn't we
have healthy people on the Mac front of
Mag I'm not saying like because they
didn't want that yeah yeah but you said
we need that earlier no but I was saying
that for the people that don't that
actually I think in my head I'm thinking
for the people that actually because a
person that actually cannot overcome
obesity and for the rest of their life
till the age of 60 70 they're still
going to be overweight those people are
probably feeling yes like they're
they're feeling okay they're you know
they're empowered
would you rather be in power than commit
suicide because people think oh look at
you but when you're when you're
overeating you're slowly committing
suicide exactly my mother did it wow she
died wow like 500 calls of death was
severe obesity and then when my daughter
started getting the weight I was
freaking out right and so that's why
we're on a mission and yeah but don't
you think there's a certain level though
obviously there's obesity and there's
because I feel like the modeling world
has always
promoted unhealthy unhealthiness and
that makes sense even the slim women
slimming women was like six and like
very small do you know what I'm saying
that would it looked like they weren't
eating exactly
I have Marilyn Mon
Roe was very slim and they wouldn't eat
or they wouldn't do something just to
fit in a certain categories you know
what I'm saying I mean there's there are
some but I just maybe for like early
2000s
but look at the last one
last like women on the covers were just
beautiful what's the average weight you
would say uh let's see I don't know off
the top of my head as a Ford Model the
the girls who are in straight size
modeling they were size four and that's
because the samples are made in a size
four
and six zero four different from uk4 it
is a bit Yeah like more like a two I
think it'd be more like a two two the
average the average woman she's gone
okay the average woman is 5'4 I'm in
America and I can do UK in a second five
four twenty years old and weighs 170
pounds oh what's that in stone please
[Music]
average Stones I don't actually know
indeed but that's overweight I would say
that that average that she just quoted
would be a 12 stone 12 12 12.14 okay
because I would think that average is
between 8 to 12. I think if you're in a
good in shape 12 there's good In-Shape
12 women
and you think about that then we're
talking obesity you know what I'm saying
um it's BMI yeah to be honest sorry uh
to be honest it depends I think like
around 10 years ago it used to be way
different I think now they kind of
raised it you know yeah yeah 10 years
ago I went I don't know I was like 65
kilos I don't know what that is sorry
and and Stones it must be like 165 in
um in America 2.2 to one yeah and they
would already say oh you should try to
lose weight you know for your hide
whatever now if you look at that they're
like yeah you're perfect you can be a
model so it really changed in the last
decade I would say really it did so it
was about around 10 years ago was there
plus size models is that a new thing
I'll be honest I'm not really we're
definitely we're on America's Next Top
Model I mean it wasn't that as common
though but I definitely I I used to
watch Tyra Banks anyone yeah yeah anyone
yeah but they weren't like this they
weren't like the the like yeah yeah like
you see today they're just kind of like
they're like tens big boned 10 things
all right yeah ten is not big no Ten's
not bigger
but this one I'm saying for the modeling
yeah but again it's like when you go to
an NBA game I want to see good
basketball players like it's supposed to
be the epitome of beauty yeah like now
we're rewarding average like I don't
want to see average chicks like faces on
the cover I don't want to see average
bodies if she's a if she's a good I'm
not saying plus plus but she's a good
size 12 with good Curves in that Amanda
want to see that we don't really want to
just see slim girls all the time I'll be
honest I believe that I believe that
some men like that I really do it's
typical to be honest it's typically
broke man because if you look at the
original yeah yeah if you look at like
it's cap like I'm just I don't I don't
Liars no offense but no no it's like
like when like when you're rich man what
do they have on their arms
but the only reason why they have slim
women is because the slim women are in
the higher echelons of places where the
other women no let's not talk about
beauty only I'm talking about venues
certain venues certain places that they
get to go to certain women can't get to
go there okay
Apria if he wanted a big chick he
couldn't find one no he couldn't find
one but I'm saying in certain the plate
the venue the events no events from
Instagram come on
they could get any chicken yeah they can
but but do you think Leonardo just got
in bad girls DMS just hollering girls
and idioms
I think he'll I think he'll pick like he
had one chick uh the Hadid
the model yeah I don't know what I say
it's like if you look at the richest
most successful man they they typically
have slim women I'm saying if you're
looking at the richest parts of events
and venues you've made fair whatever and
in America Manhattan whatever if you go
to the upper echelons or places you know
what I'm saying do you really think that
the only reason they're with slim
beautiful women is because of the events
they go to no but I'm saying because of
the environment that they're in okay I
think that was because that would that
is society's ideal of a beautiful woman
that's why and so I feel like the plus
model came in when people started
complaining that there wasn't a
selection of varieties why is it that
all around the world they like young
beautiful slim women everywhere even in
different societies with completely
different cultures please
please do not bring out this one
fringent tribe in Africa everyone brings
up but it's like they're it's such a
small percentage of the world well
Africa there's something Africa they
bring up some tribe in Africa assist
that likes the fat women but it's a very
very I've done this conversation well if
you think ahead but if you think about
is the motherland
continuous
me coming no you know deep down you know
that men like slim women in general I'm
gonna be honest I don't think they do
I'm gonna be honest and I'm gonna say
this coming from
being a black man okay if I'm talking
about being a black man or from a black
perspective of I feel like majority of
us men like thicker women okay well and
and even me Jordan yeah but you keep
talking about celebrity men that are
going to be around to hire women that
are that certain women I'm from a one
person not a family my dad my dad my dad
is a top one percent earner I grew up
around in a wealthy neighborhood I'm
telling you they do not put fat chicks
on their arms in high class in high
class society and celebrities want
people with the option to not have a fat
chick on their arm do not all right well
even like what's having a conversation
the other day with with a woman and she
was a slim woman she's from America as
well so American
um I think Atlanta or whatever and she
said when she was slim she was only
getting approached by white men okay she
put she put on a lot of weight no not a
lot of weight watchers these tips got
body whatever blah blah now she's
getting approached by a lot of black men
which is what do you get on what I'm
saying if you if you look at it on on
the Democrat thing which which
successful black men that we know are
dating well we're only going to talk
about successful yeah because those are
the men with options broke men don't
have as many options as rich men
definitely have options they do not have
as many options as Richmond so if you
look at the men with the most options to
look okay so if we want to see what
women want we got to look at the women
with the most options who do the most
beautiful the youngest most fertile
women pick if you want to look at men
what do men like we have to look at the
men with the most options because it's
not really fair to say oh I like fat
chicks if I make you know ten dollars an
hour at Taco Bell right like you can't
you don't guess
[Laughter]
obviously if you're going if you're
talking about celebrity celebrities are
guided but I didn't just say celebrities
I'm from I'm my dad is in like he's a
top one percent earner I grew up with 10
siblings in a 10 bedroom mansion in a
community where many people made that
amount of money yeah so so I've been
around a successful wealthy man and they
don't put fat chicks sometimes they they
do get fat later but they don't
appreciate that you know what I mean so
yeah but I hear what you're saying what
I'm saying the reason these men
obviously going to go for Slimmer
because they're around that's what you
being in the top one percent and being
in in this neighborhood okay it allows
you to see different things together
no but if you do have obviously if you
do have money a lot of people with money
are in the gym they do it because they
have more time on their hands to do
other things you get what I'm saying no
they have less time it's a guarantees
schedule people absolutely have less
time totally no I don't know no no I
could tell you 100 but also I think the
reason that a lot lot of women are
Slimmer and why do you think more
successful men want women who are
Slimmer it's because it's healthier for
them like their risk for getting you
know diseases at an older age their risk
for having pregnancy risks are much
lower if they're not overweight yeah so
why would a man choose a woman if he
wants to marry them if they're going to
die at 50 if they're going to die at 70
if they're going to have their
children's gonna have to be at risk for
birth risk I mean I would never want
that and I don't think I don't think men
want that like when men are looking for
wives they're not looking for like women
who are going to have risks and we even
saw how for you how your bad habit
passed on to her and that's like if you
have a bad habit yourself you will pass
it on to your kids and then it's another
problem that your kid like because I had
the same my mom used to feed me like
Pop-Tarts and stuff when I was a kid and
I and my mom was pretty big and then she
ended up like losing all the weight
um and she told me like she literally
did it for my dad
um and
um yeah I have a sugar addiction to this
day you know what I mean so it's like
bad habits pass from like the parents to
the kids exactly and sugar is more
addictive than cocaine yeah crazy yeah I
do miss Pop-Tarts they make healthy pop
darts but they're really not healthy
they're still junk food no I said I
don't like I like the cinnamon one
I wanted the complete opposite direction
like total Neurosis I got my bachelor's
master's degree in nutrition I helped
thousands of people lose weight regain
their health and it was almost like her
Rebellion so her choice to gain autonomy
through overeating and ill health was
almost you know well it was just so so
crazy for me because I was so happy I
thought you said you were overweight as
a kid I was but as an adult what were
you doing my whole life until I was like
15 I was like rebelling against her I
was like I'm gonna eat all the junk food
so I'd go to my friend's house stuff my
face with pizza and then their moms
would call her and be like oh my gosh is
your daughter okay she's eating like a
box of pizza and like my whole box of
goldfish wow and I would just do that
and then I come home moment I would
never like her cooking even though she's
the best cook I know but like I would I
just rebelled my whole life yeah it was
terrible uh James says there's a
difference between fit and thick men
want fit women
um puffy I'm in Las Vegas and I see
plenty of women from Africa I am black
this is Cap we like thin women
and then I think there was one more I'm
just gonna do really quick uh lady in
the red is telling the truth I've lost
67 pounds my life is better off these
plus size influencers are lying to
people example lizzo yeah what do you
think of lizzo so I actually recently
did a video on this um I set up Podcast
but basically lizzo is portraying
something that is terrible for a young
woman and then you have thousands of
young women saying oh my gosh those are
so beautiful everyone should be like
lizzo and then you have all the fat
people looking at lizzo feeding off of
her positivity her body positivity and
why does she lead with it too like she's
her brand like make people say yeah
nobody would talk when Adele was
overweight nobody really spoke about her
wait because she didn't lead with her
you know they did speak about it when
she lost the weight right they were like
oh we can't believe you lost weight we
hate you now like we don't like you like
you did this for for social media and
it's like what yeah what about doing
this to save her life why aren't more
people supporting right women losing
weight that's what real body positivity
because we know the whole world is lazy
the majority of people so that it fits
well also the food industry benefits the
food industry and the medical industry
to have more overweight people because
then you have more surgeries than you
have more medications being handed out
then you have more depression anxiety
suicide I mean the divorce rates you
know it's right it's insane right no I
mean honestly like one time I was at
work and these guys were like like
clowning on women over 200 pounds
they're like oh I would never do but
they didn't know I was because I like I
don't look like I didn't look like I was
over 200 right and literally I ended up
like losing a bunch of weight because I
was so embarrassed and I and then it was
the best thing that ever happened to me
I ran a marathon because I was like I'm
done I'm done with this but
run a marathon yeah or
to exercise too like I remember being in
that place I went to the doctor's office
actually and that's when I started I
they were like your triglycerides are up
your your aristic heart disease type 2
diabetes and you know if you don't start
now you are gonna die very like slowly
but soon and I was terrified I was like
what just from being fat I was wow how
long did they say you had
I'm
curious like how long do 300 pound
people live I don't do you know I don't
know the stats on that yeah I know but
they they definitely have a higher risk
of cardiovascular disease which is a
number one killer they have a higher
risk of cancer they definitely will
develop Diabetes Type 2 and other
diseases that are 100 professional
there's that influencer that just like
dropped dead the other day because she
was obese and like she would literally
always be eating and doing mukbangs then
she died I'm not surprised yeah why do
you think she died everyone you know now
they say and then they say like when
obese people go to the doctor and they
say to lose weight that they're like not
listening to them but I'm like well I
mean I'm not a doctor but you might want
to like watch for your but even doctors
are lying to people now saying oh it's
okay to eat like cheeseburgers they
can't weigh you they can't weigh you
either even that and it's like you guys
why are you lying to these people who
actually some people who actually want
to be helped are being lied to yeah oh
just do the keto diet oh just do the
paleo diet it'll be fine that's not a
long-term Solution that's not a
lifestyle right doctors aren't really
even trained in nutrition they don't
know how to help and the business model
isn't set up for them to support their
their patients so it's the whole model
is flawed and we really need to get
smart and get responsible and to be
clear about what we're putting in our
thoughts in our minds and in our in our
mouths literally they said as an African
woman Zimbabwean we are curvy there's a
big difference between being curvy and
over weight you can be thin and curvy
and just big big uh and then there's
another one that was from interracial
marriages our relationships for black
men Community we value bigger women
because they make for better sex
partners
marriage is different requirements for
than sex my thin women or my thin woman
felt like she was too pretty to fulfill
my sexual requirements
um okay so how did you say how does a
man identify a good woman
I would say that a man identifies a good
woman if she's one healthy and fit
that's important okay especially for
childbearing and I'd say number two if
she has Traditional Values if she
believes in being submissive if she
believes in being feminine she she she
she loves to answer that question
we're gonna get to the men okay
don't worry
it was just whoever is sitting you know
and then I think if she wants to cook if
she's okay cleaning she wants she's a
homemaker she would love to you know
have children and take care of them and
be a housewife I think that's beautiful
and so that's what I think identifies a
good woman okay
um what about you well identifying as a
good woman nowadays is a bit difficult
however I would emphasize on the values
and uh the morals of the woman
um primarily her ability to be a good
wife her ability to raise good children
and even her thoughts and the things she
has in mind because she's going to be
molding the Next Generation and uh so
how does he know well it can because you
know women lie like we can just say
things like I'm
but you know if you have a deep
conversation with a person
but believe me throughout time you can
identify okay so how much how much time
if it's um I would say I would give it
like three months but it can okay so
three months of constant um
constant uh meeting
okay so you think in three months he can
see if she has traditional value yes
okay she would I mean just so healthy so
he can look she healthy and fit cool
yeah
um is she how can he test if she's
submissive
he can ask something and see the
reaction so ask her to do something and
see what she does for example you can
tell I mean as if a man tells to a woman
can you uh please make me a coffee or a
meal and she said hell no I'm not doing
this to you I mean that's all right
she's here for three months ask her to
make him a coffee
okay
[Laughter]
what
okay uh what what else can he do how
does he act uh does he like what else
what else does he do I mean well uh
because I was here just find a good
woman so I'm just trying to get from the
women how did the men just find a good
woman
yeah it's his ability to identify what
he values in in a woman okay I mean
that's gonna be subjective to an extent
yeah so I'm asking like what what makes
someone a good woman and how does he
identify that
I think what you were saying is Well men
do test women I've been tested by men
like with certain things so like oh can
you cook for me can you make me food or
like on the spot though I asked to it
really happened you know it's a good
test it really happens and then he'll
know if do you know how to cook can you
cook properly properly even your
presentation
step by step further well I'm gonna let
the men talk I'm just curious how it's
going to align with what you guys say
from the women and the men
um okay so first he's got to see her for
three months ask her to make him a
coffee and ask to cook oh I disagree
with all of that I think that honestly
if it's a high value man most of the
time he's gonna know without all of that
honestly most of them nowadays how does
he know
um there is this I don't know if it's
the right word but there is this Aura
there is this sense when you sit with a
woman who you know is going to be
respectful to you or not I honestly feel
that you think that average men just
know this because you're talking about
high value that's like yeah that's like
five percent but average man nowadays
look at high value men's content more
and more and more okay and try to see so
you think and I think you think I'm just
curious you think men just know
they don't just know but they should get
to a point
to just know so they they have so how so
how does he get to that point that he
just knows well slowly slowly slowly
we're getting to a point where I think
they need to go to certain parts of the
world to know and certain parts of the
world they will just know that 90 of the
women will not be like that and okay so
he has to he needs to travel too slowly
we're getting he needs to travel
somewhere else and then experience those
women and then compare exactly exactly
okay but for for a guy that doesn't
travel like he stays in the west because
most remember most guys don't make a ton
of money like I think half of uh us men
don't have passports yeah so so most men
aren't traveling like that so forgot
it's not traveling how does he know good
woman versus bad woman I would say if
you if the first conversation with her
is like oh so where are we going to
dinner are we having drinks this is not
a right way to to meet I think when you
meet a girl you should take her for
coffee and that's it even if you like
her so much that you take on a coffee
date and see what she's like and see if
she he's I don't know if she wants to
continue the date and get you to buy her
dinner and can a man know a good woman
from a bad woman without experiencing a
lot of women
no not really okay so so in order to
identify he asked what
uh he I would suggest that in in his 20s
he dates as many women as he can that's
right that's right okay okay so so how
many women should he date
yeah as much as you can I'm not saying
sleep with all of them
date as many women as possible to tell
the difference I read because again
remember I just want to remind everybody
the stats one out of three women has an
STD one out of three women has had an
abortion 38 of women are of kids are
born into single parent homes meaning 38
of the Next Generation has never seen a
functioning marriage
um average child first child is before
the average age of first marriage so the
first kid 26 first marriage 30 half of
marriage is will end in divorce average
number of partners for a woman is
between four and eight
um and
that's self-reported so you know take
that with a grain of salt but women have
a 20 chance of being in a happy marriage
if they have slept with more than five
people so
um yeah and if men get divorced they can
be financially ruined and their kids can
be taken from them um 70 of women are
overweight so basically there's a lot
riding on them picking the right woman
so I'm trying to give them a foolproof
plan
that makes sense there's a book that I
read called sex a Dawn and in this book
they were making a case basically for a
polyamory and polyamorous relationships
which I don't resonate with personally
but I was trying to convince myself
because everyone else seems to think
that's a good idea except for me so I
thought well I gotta read this book but
at the end of the book they had a very
interesting fact about the olfactory
um sense right your nose like actually
we sniff each other out
a woman can tell if a man will
compliment her differences genetically
I've heard that yeah and then but a
woman actually can't if she's taking
birth control
oh it's disabled but a man can actually
sniff her out he can genetically
identify through his olfactory you know
sense through his nose whether or not
she'll complement his genetic weaknesses
so how does he know what does he have to
smell for I don't know that's a good
question
but apparently it's like a deep very
primal thing about so maybe attraction
maybe make sure she's not on birth
control yes right for example not on
birth control I think that works both
ways now I wonder what percent hold on I
wanna I just want to look up because I'm
curious what percent of women are on
birth control also who hears on birth
control raise your hand no one not
anymore I mean clearly one out of three
are having abortion so I'm like it can't
be that high
uh the majority uh but oh ninety percent
of women have used conscious deceptives
throughout their reproductive years
um and have used more than one in their
lifetime 76 percent
wow okay we just have a good room I
guess I'm gonna add that to my stats
okay
um sorry can I just add one more thing
that came to my mind
um ask her about the family you know
sometimes I do understand that not all
of the parents can stay together of
course there are special situations but
just see how she talks about her family
what is her relationship like with her
family and her her Dad too you know so
if a girl even if a girl is not in on
good terms with her dad but she
disrespects him by talking trash to a
guy that's not a girl that you should
marry honestly and if I don't think you
can disagree with this because there's
no even if you haven't got a great
relationship with your or your father's
absent it doesn't mean that the woman is
going to be a wreck it is
why do we have the phrase daddy issues
if it doesn't mean anything but some
most people will not okay a lot of
people that have daddy issues and we
don't know who they are I'm one of them
but I'm not a disrespectful person to
men like I'm not well yeah we're not
talking about you but in general like
it's your dad no matter what like I
think if you've never if you've never
seen a healthy relationship how would
you know how to do it exactly like if
I've never seen anyone ride a bike how
would I learn to ride a bike it's common
sense I feel like it's like morality if
it was common then why do half of
relationships end in divorce and why is
the older generation known for being so
unhappy in their marriages because men
pick women based off the off the surface
they don't actually get uh get to find a
deeper meaning if women swipe right on
dating apps which is the most
superficial only five percent of the
time immensely bright fifty percent of
the time who's more superficial men or
women women but mostly men are hoes
that's incorrect one out of three men
are either virgins or haven't had sex
around one out of one out of three men
or either virgin or haven't had sex in
the past year wow I think a lot of women
sleep around so yeah a lot of women do
sleep right now
so you're saying we're the same yeah
it's like 20 of men are [__] all the
girls essentially in their 20s and then
when women hit 30 they'll expand it like
basically like women typically go for
looks in their 20s
um women pick like when women this is
the first time in history where women
have been the sexual selectors so like
historically think about it you had to
get along with the dude or you die yeah
like they would pay they would pick you
you wouldn't pick them uh but now this
is the first time where women have been
100 in control of reproduction because
we have birth control we're in control
of abortion so we are 100 in control of
who's born and it's funny because the
more freedom women get the more we screw
the same people in our Prime which is
like 22 to 24
um they surveyed men between like 20 and
80 and they said when do you find women
most attractive it's like roughly 22 to
24 all the ages think that so when women
have the most Choice it's interesting
because we pick non-monogamy
and we and we tend to go for looks and
women react out of emotion yeah solely
out of emotion a lot of the time right
why you see so many women sleeping with
so many men and making decisions on the
spot that aren't responsible like
abortion yeah so but majority of women
not going for men that's not monogamous
then why they fight for man to be
monogamous
I mean I think they want him to be but
so they want to change the man basically
they see a man
for the top 20 or whatever which they
know is they can tell that he gets a lot
of girls or whatever yeah so they want
to try and lock down that one man so you
don't yeah okay I mean I think that's
like every girl's you know it has a you
know what Cinderella was sitting at home
and the prince like came and picked her
out of all the princesses exactly they
want to say either changed him they've
been selling us this dream forever
exactly exactly
um so what do you what do you think of
that does that change your perspective a
little bit
um
not right kinda not really no okay what
does it not change I just still think
that
um
men are looking for things they don't
have themselves they look they don't
have the minerals for the things that
they want in the women so they just pick
women based off looks they don't know
what they want anyway they think they
know what they want but they haven't
even got the minerals anyway is it
possible that women don't have what they
want absolutely right absolutely so how
would they pick it if the dating pool
has like one out of every three women's
had an abortion one of every three women
has an STD
um like 38 40 grew up without a dad so
they don't have that model like how
would they
where how would they know yeah who the
good woman is yeah like they've never
like what percent of men have like even
seen a true traditional woman I don't
think yeah do you know any women with
like recipe books only only that the
highest celebrities those two but only
like the upper High celebrity profile
people yeah and then these two now yeah
okay and my whole family and then when I
go there they're like oh so modern you
know everyone still Cooks the same meals
and
um but so I'm just curious like when
you're hearing these stats like assuming
I'm telling you the truth you don't
think like it puts more of the
promiscuity on women because we're only
sleeping with 20 of men so like that
means 80 of us are sleeping with 20 of
men
like okay I'll give you an example how
tall was your last boyfriend
um six one okay what percent of men do
you think are six one
maybe like
it's not it's not six one thirty percent
ten percent
so you had a top did how much money did
he make well you had he had his own
houses and a business he sells cars okay
so roughly well how much do you think he
made
yeah okay so if he owned a house he
probably made at least like 60 70 I
guess who knows he had a nice range okay
so he's he's probably like I'm guessing
right I don't actually know you guys
would know London prices more than me
but he's probably still top 20 of income
probably because buying a house in Essex
is cheap yeah okay so top 20 so you had
a guy top 10 high top 20 income was he
attractive was he good looking yeah he
was yeah so in women so you know women
we find 80 of men is ugly
so if you find him attractive that means
he's top 20 right you should maybe call
him because he's still singing no he's
been trying to honor it me to be honest
I don't have to block him
he's not the one for me what is the one
so it seems like he has a good job
attractive and Tall his person
no no it's not I'm very smart trust me
like he was wearing a mask when we first
met and then his true colors came out
and I saw it in certain behaviors that
he was portraying what true colors so
like you know he was very aggressive
sometimes and he I felt like his mom
what do you mean aggressive did he hit
you
no no he didn't hit me no okay so he
didn't well he pushed me he shoved me
very hard and it was for a very pathetic
reason and he's alive did you shove him
at all no just once no I don't like to
be aggressive I don't believe in that
[__] no more I've grown up you know okay
so he he shoved you one time yeah and it
was very and it was petty and he lied at
the time as well and I knew he was lying
about picking up his kids when he wasn't
go he he changed his story like I'm very
observant picking up his kids so I spent
a couple days with him and he and I was
supposed to say the last day and he and
then he all of a sudden he's got to go
and pick up his kids but you're lying
and so it's like you're making me feel
like you don't want to seem you don't
wanna you don't want to stay anymore so
and then that happened then we broke up
and now he wants me back I know he went
picking up his kids I know he wasn't
because his story changed he told me
something we planned something from the
get-go so I know so so I didn't you
don't have no physical evidence of that
I do I do I do it's very it's very
technical but you think I'm crazy if I
go into it right now how did the shoving
happen like what what led up to that
because he wanted me to leave okay so
usually and chat
okay okay
why do a lot of women like they accuse a
man of being like the bad guy the guy
that hurts them the guy that beats them
but then the reason they like they made
they caused the reason because if you
physically don't move in certain spaces
it's the way you speak to someone it's
the way you conduct yourself in that
situation but if you're in this has
happened to me before I've been Esther
you know you know um
I'm not here and I asked her to leave
and she didn't like the way I asked her
to leave right and then she starts
yelling at me
um and then
um well we didn't have security then but
my security would have just picked her
up and taking her 100. but then it's
like the way you're saying this it's
like the other options
see the thing I would have done that but
when it's an emotional sexual connection
you've got other feelings like you feel
rejection you feel like you're being
violated but it's kind of different
you're kind of so you're kind of making
yourself so basically like you were kind
of overbearing because he you thought he
did something and you had no proof he
did it no I did because he said what he
changed his story but you've never said
two things that contradicted yourself
ever I I have I just happens when you
talk it's very easy to say the wrong
thing if you're being cross-examined
because you know what when you say
earlier on where am I not analyzing
women and women are analyzing man he's
looking at you like raw so you're gonna
argue against me picking up my kids
however you know it's not all it is yeah
in his head right hold on I'm telling
you something about my kids and you're
arguing against my kids
to him
does he ever write to privacy
of course absolutely
maybe there is something that he just
didn't want you to know maybe he was
Private with the mud like you know I
mean like baby mama situations can be
tricky like sometimes guys don't want to
get you in on all the drama but it's
like you're going into it in bad face so
you're assuming the worst when maybe it
wasn't the worst but I also feel like
it's just the way you conduct yourself
in a sense a situation as well it's like
I just feel like couldn't we say that to
you though because it's the way like you
didn't listen when he said leave so it's
kind of like as women like we kind of
have this double standard where we make
him the bad guy when it's like you kind
of started it but then oh yeah I
remember now also the reason was like
I've stayed in the house by myself
before and at this point he like he
didn't want me to stay so it's like if
you love me why can't I stay here while
you go and pick up your child do what
you need to do and I'll stay here
tonight and you come back because he's
because that's entitled
if I own this apartment if I if I want
anyone to leave at any time I have the
right to do that like that wasn't the
issue I honestly I didn't have an issue
with that it was just the way it
happened and the things that he was
saying and the way he was speaking to me
it was kind of like but this is like a
lot of problems with women in
relationships we want men to emote like
women but he's not a woman he's a man
men don't speak like women do like
they're much more Stern and so a lot of
times like we think something's
aggressive but men are just more
aggressive than women you might want to
call them but we're not aggressive he
seems like a hard man to replace
them and you said in the beginning that
the men that like you you don't want so
that means then you want don't want you
wow I haven't met the one I think no but
that's like that's what any girl that's
single it just means the men you want
don't want you and it's not meant to be
the thing is it's actually crazy because
there's no one I actually want
apart from there's okay but okay come on
there's nobody in the world that you'd
want I'm attracted to like someone but
he's but he's like a celebrity figure
you're like sex appeal but there's no
one I actually think okay do you think
you're on like the level of a celebrity
yeah
I think I think I
think I am no you're you're pretty I
think I'm an amazing person
celebrities like top 10 20 of beauty
like that yeah but remember I think I'm
beautiful I think I'm beautiful without
the botox without without the money
without all that money to do myself up
so I think I'm great this is like a cope
I see women do like it's like you you
think because they have money they're be
they're beautiful when they got there
money helped but if you look at Margot
Robbie before fame that girl was a 10. I
don't know who that is but then you're
doing selectiveness because there's
enough girl that go there and the money
blows them up only
I disagree not the girls that get there
for looks alone top 20 of beauty you can
look at exceptions like that like Kylie
Jenner she's not she's not beautiful she
wasn't beautiful before nah she was cute
but yeah I mean she wasn't that
beautiful she gets fixed up she wasn't
but but like I'm just saying in general
guys like can we just talk in general
instead of exceptions most celebrities
are top 20 of Beauty in general
and like we could talk about there's
some exceptions like Kylie Jenner did
her lips whatever but most most people
in Hollywood were the top 20 of beauty
wherever they're from
student agreed but yeah okay I feel you
I feel you
I don't know maybe you should call him
no definitely not
a closure but he's not the one for me
he's not my definition of the one
I just feel like there's a different
there's a difference in Behavior and the
way you feel as well I can accept I'm
not a possessive person I can accept I
really like my Independence but I just
know there's a certain way that you will
handle someone in those situations
sorry I just know within myself sorry
are you your only child no I've got
brother and sister are you the youngest
I'm in the middle oh okay you know so
girl
so growing up did you did your mom have
a partner do you have a stepdad no no
yeah yeah like no but not permanently so
what in terms of looking at do you know
how to look after a manly of like oh
being a noble because you're saying
certain things that in a relationship is
like
if you saw a relationship with your mom
and dad growing up then there's certain
things you wouldn't do in a relationship
you guys saying to keep the man
listen every man every every man that's
been my boyfriend has returned and they
haven't found better yeah
yeah you've been proposed to have been
engaged not like on on one knee I
haven't had that experience yet but I've
had similar he bought you around yes
I've had similar but not like that we
was young so I promise me basically kind
of like okay
okay it is what it's the same thing it's
rare for some amount to do that promise
rings don't captain no it does because
it's rare because it does not do you
think that meant get go out and buy
promise rings
[Music]
but he doesn't really like you to be
because he's not going to do that to
everyone no no I'm not gonna lie okay
it's never gonna happen it doesn't count
you need a wedding date yeah a wedding
date not not a little ring but I was
young anyway no okay so it wasn't a real
it wasn't a real proposal no no no no no
okay so so the whole point is like
you're counting things that don't count
it doesn't count if they don't want to
marry not for you well they do their
intention is no like men say things when
they mean it they do it
um like you can't you can't count it
like I know what you mean but you know
[__] happens you know I've had guys say
I want to marry you it doesn't count
unless he goes by the Rings this is 100
we can't like like I don't know why I
was count things that don't count you
know it don't count it so probably
you've been proposed to a couple times
I don't count like
so no one's a ring and said no no no it
doesn't it don't count like it's like
I've had a promise ring there's a
promise ring a wedding ring no no it's
not I don't count that by the time we
feel like it but did he say it was a
promise ring or did he say it's an
engagement ring no he said it was a
promise ring and then he said he was
trying to he said it doesn't count
that's what I'm saying financially he
was trying to get there like the
property
um okay how so everyone went right how
does a guy identify a good woman yeah
random time okay all right man if you
want to say how do I one are any of you
with a good woman
like like anyone married anyone marries
we're not married yet no no married okay
I just wanted to get okay how do you
find a good woman how do I find one yeah
identical one
um I think a good woman I can't I can't
throw a good woman straight away it has
to be a longer coaster time she needs to
be our one when I won when I need her to
be and I won't get that from the first
look basis you know I mean so I think at
first
um a good woman to me
is a woman that has
good family values that don't have to
be around a family that has a good
relationship with her dad
um submissive
um
caring nurturing
healthy
that's about it all right caring that's
about it from you uh and how do you know
a good one so right now this is what you
have to do you have to see her for three
months yeah ask her to make you a coffee
that's three month things three months
um this is for the woman you picked to
marry so like okay and you can make
edits so it's okay
um take on a coffee date for first date
okay date as many women as possible to
tell the difference make sure she's not
on birth control and figure out what her
relationship's like with her family and
her dad what do you agree with disagree
with them would you like to add
[Music]
there's a lot of don't need to add to
that man um
[Music]
you know when the biggest change of a
woman happens which has a baby for me
that's when I see the biggest change in
a woman so you won't even really know
your woman until she has a child
properly
in order to find a good woman you have
to get him no you don't have to but I'm
saying
no you're not after you well it's a
certain things you'll see but I'm saying
from my experience I have three kids in
it so
I saw the biggest change when the woman
had a child okay so how
long yeah marry your knock her up
whatever I don't know about Mario not
corrupt three months is a good time to
determine whether she's being genuine
because she's wearing a Moscow yeah so
you got to see her for three months in
order to date her like what's that how
many years I don't think you as he said
you can't really determine anyone as the
true person as they're being genuine as
they say they are for like the first
three months January if you've lived
with someone that's different if you
move in with some you can see the truth
like a lot quicker actually can I can I
I'm sorry I'm a little add sometimes
when when do you guys expect to sleep
with her
yeah expect expectation is a big word
expectation I don't have expectations
I'll be honest yeah I don't think
there's too much of it's not a problem
if you sleep with a woman the first
night or you sleep with a woman two
months down the line because man could
move different man couldn't wait without
a woman with her as soon as you can yeah
because you couldn't you couldn't sleep
with a woman straight away and have a
great connection and a great
relationship with her or you can a woman
can hold out for six months or whatever
and there's man out here that will sit
there for six months
all right
how long is too long no matter how good
the girl is you ain't waiting like this
is really three months is the month okay
okay I want hands for the men are you
waiting one all right wait wait wait
wait
are we waiting a week is that okay all
right
okay I need you to go I'm you put your
hand up when it's too long okay all
right two weeks
three weeks
he said he said you're putting in three
weeks it depends on the context I mean
has she made other people wait you don't
know them yeah
I mean like how how old is she like I
mean it's just some kind of born-again
Virgin I don't know I don't know
first date like so you don't know you've
just met her off the street whatever
dating app whatever so you have to
determine all right so three weeks you
can wait you're not you're he's okay
four weeks four weeks too long for
anyone no five weeks okay two months too
long
to sleep with her the two months is the
max all right after that yeah
yeah I get bored easily so after two
months I might two two months yeah I'll
go I'll go with two to three months two
to three months all right so three all
right so you guys two you said I don't
know but the thing is I've done three
months when I was young maybe when I'm
older now I don't I don't know that's
why I'm in but when I had the three
months
relationship lost oh you meet a nice
woman do you think you're looking for
she's the one
you have to know
right you have to be in our life for
that whole time I understand her how old
are you again I'm 29. okay you're 29. so
how old women do you usually date around
my age so if she's not a building will
you wait for a year for her
she's not a virgin when I wait for a
year if I was yeah I could do I could do
it's not likely I could do are you
sleeping with other people at the time
you're waiting yeah
[Laughter]
the average the out the nice I don't
know your favorite girl that you've been
on a date with let's just take her you
guys can think of whoever your favorite
ex is whatever all right would you have
waited a year for her
yeah I did oh you did okay
um so you'll wait a year you'll wait two
months two months you'll wait what
when you say now you're saying favorite
yeah
you know what I would wait visually I
would wait but one of the if you're
talking about favorites it didn't last
it didn't take long it was first time no
but how long would you wait for a girl
you liked that's what I'm saying I I
just use that as you know giving no no I
can't answer that question please answer
the question you're here to answer my
questions
give me an answer please it doesn't have
to be set I would wait too much yeah two
months okay thank you thank you so much
you're like three weeks roughly a month
a month yeah so one month two months a
year we gotta yeah okay so step one
sleep with her as soon as possible
and way up to are you up to one month
to a year
on the guy because what if you wait a
year and you don't like it um
I wasn't only in that one into that one
so you know what I'm saying yeah
okay well okay so don't wait now we're
going back don't wait uh I don't know
just just for him though he's waiting
yeah okay so next step okay so when
should you ask her to make you a coffee
that's what we have
okay so what what else how else do you
bat to for a good woman
you know what
the good woman yeah I think you need it
depends on the communication and the
conversation that you have so go and
coffee is
I agreeable and the maddest thing is the
girl I'm seeing now the this is the
first time I've ever gone coffee and we
had a mad conversation in Costa over
coffee and I've never done that before
which is mad but what I'm telling you
well once you have a good comment
through conversation and through certain
things a man would get an idea so like
what adding on to what Rome's the same
with family values traditional maybe
even fear of God like conversations with
her you understand a lot more about it
you know I'm saying if she could can she
even conversate can we have a proper
conversation together you know what I'm
saying
okay so take on coffee date sleep with
her as soon as possible coffee day after
I finish waiting
oh oh so that yeah okay I know coffee
day after you finish waiting that's a
waste of time nah man you gotta go first
what okay
go on coffee date either before or after
you sleep with her
can I just say really quickly I promise
the reason why you could say that now is
because you're in a position to be open
to be receptive to her as well you know
some guys would be like what you know
like we're going clubbing or you know it
depends on the man as well yeah 100 I'm
not going to blame on the man but it's a
two-way street a lot of police list
Manhattan so I've probably gone through
dating women going through this gone
through that so now when I meet someone
I can analyze a good woman to get what
I'm saying yeah and it's through
actually I feel like to your question of
where's all the good women gone yeah I
feel like a lot of good women
don't have the values of back in the day
so women I don't know back in there
because I wasn't born back in the day
but I think a lot of women don't want to
show wife credentials before they're a
wife so they will hold things back
expecting you to put a ring on their
finger
because it's like oh I I can do this but
I'm not going to do these until I'm your
wife but I'm thinking man I think him
right if you're gonna cool there's other
girl out here that's going to show me
what a wife is but imagine acting like a
wife and doing full for all that
cooking's different but Full Throttle
acting like a wife for you to go and see
someone else or play around but if you
don't do that the man's gone so if you
so do you want to show him do you want
to show him that you're all right
because a man coming into a show when
you're ready I'm a husband promotion
don't you do the job that he gives me
first or do you say promote me with no
work experience because you know what if
I if me okay one second me and you are
in a relationship or we're building up a
relationship and then we go out
I'm here to protect you but I had to
stand there and just watch you when we
go home now what are you gonna say no no
one would I mean no no don't say no one
will do that you can't say no one
because there's man out here that's not
going to protect you so our job is to
our job
okay forget the semantics my job is to
protect and provide for you if I don't
protect you when I'm out with you and
you're rolling out with me when we go
home what are you saying to me
whatever the situation where you need
protecting and I don't protect you in
that situation what are you doing after
that situation I don't I can't answer
that question because I don't know what
you mean by protective you're deciding
that he's not the one that doesn't make
it's happened to me before there was
like an accident yeah in Costa Rica
there was like a canoeing thing and a
kayak thing and he didn't show up and I
was I really questioned my future with
this guy that was for me it was done
done
yeah so if you don't show up all right
he didn't but if you don't show your
wife credentials to the man what do you
think he's gonna do the thing is there's
an extent there's a limit you can't do
everything because you don't know if
that man's serious yet you don't know
what's going on but you can't do
everything and I'm not you're not out
here
like that's the thing like you're going
into something in bad faith oh I can't
do much too much for him otherwise he
might not pick me up anyway yeah but but
it's like you're going into things in
fear and you don't get anything worth
having if you go into [__] scared
exactly like you can get your heart
broke like it happens scared money don't
make no money yeah but it's like you
have to in order to okay in order to to
start this whole podcast I had to invest
first but women want all the outcomes
without having to invest anything
because I feel like it's a two-way thing
yeah well she just said a husband has to
come to him it's a two-way thing why
does the wife don't you think Paul is a
two-way thing so if I'm if I'm it's 50
50 and then you're both on the same page
that's different
I'm not gonna do the most and you're
doing the lead okay so I have a question
do you when you go on date two pays
he does but I will pay I can pay you
know I didn't say you can pay I said who
pays the guy will okay so why does he
have to invest in you before he's before
you slept but can I tell you something
yes no no no like we have to think about
this why does he have to invest in you
before you've slept with him but I've
done that before to men I've paid on
first dates no I'm offered like you know
I
have done I'm talking about what
typically happens you're a pretty girl I
know these I know these men pay for you
I feel like men I feel like men are in
um a stereotypical mindset where they
feel like they're the big they're the
big man they have to be responsible for
paying for a first date and stuff like
that so I feel like that's why they do
it automatically men are traditional men
are more you you're right men are in
more traditional roles than women so
it's like the men are coming to you in a
traditional role they're taking you on a
date they're paying but you're you're
saying I can't be a traditional woman
for him I can't give him wifely duties
when off the bat before he even knows if
he's gonna get sex from you which is
what men want right he's
200 pounds uh nothing to you guys so
raise your hand of 200 pounds if the
investment goes right it's great if it
doesn't go right okay okay if one is 200
pounds of nothing so none of these men
are men
of course they're men but there's
different calibers of men okay they're
they're not they're not the right
caliber yeah what's the caliber what's
that about no but I'm I just know you
know
I have a certain type of mind like I
like a man that's you know I wanna I
wanna I wanna man that's like a leader
in a high position that that can teach
me because I want to be in that place
too so and you're willing to show with
nothing no I listen like I said 200
pounds ain't nothing to a man you could
show him everything and he would just
and he could possibly not be serious of
you and be speaking to another girl or
sleeping with someone else and that's
the that's the only reason
no until I know that you're serious I
will give I can get I can surrender to
you seriously you're not even respecting
a man's pocket on the first day like I
said 200 pounds is nothing you don't
respect the money because you just said
it's nothing because you're looking at
it
unless he speaks he's not able to afford
to go on a date or whatever
you know no man is gonna stay anything
man could have his last 200 pounds bro
you don't date when you're broke
so you can't
well
no you said 200 pounds ain't nothing to
it man yeah and then when and then when
all of these guys said no that is
something to me you shat on them you
said that you said they're not a high
enough caliber of man but I'm saying
from my experience
um they people have paid and I've been
on dates and I've never spoke to a
person again after and they spent a lot
of money you know what I mean you're not
valuing their time and money because you
think that every single one of them
that's spending that money whether it's
100 pound or 200 pounds you think all of
them have got it there's some man
that'll probably have taken you out on
date and that's their loss probably but
I would never know exactly so then but
you're still not respecting their money
I I don't think about it like that
exactly because you're so you're still
saying that you you can't give them too
much but they're spending 200 pounds on
you on the first date but I don't think
the way guys go on they act like money's
nothing to them and they and they're you
know what I mean so why would I would be
so conscious like unless I love you and
I know about your financial situation
it'll be completely okay but this is the
thing you're just not appreciative
because you're saying
you're not I'm listening to you speak
does she come off appreciative to anyone
no no no I'm not an ungrateful person
okay but I'm listening to you speak if I
liked a guy and I spoke to my level and
he came to me and said I can't even
afford to take you out in a certain
place I would not have a problem with
that believe me you just you just said
it ain't nothing to a man I went out
there right but I said when all the guys
in here said no that is something to me
because you said you said they are not
the caliber of man you insulted them not
really so I said broke men don't date
that's why I said okay so a man's broke
if he doesn't want to spend 200 pounds
again I'm from I'm from one percent like
top earning family my like broke men can
just not want to spend 200 pounds on
someone they don't know they don't have
to yeah but I don't ask for it's not the
best you know what if a man really likes
you and he's into you he will spend his
last 200 pounds without you knowing but
I wouldn't have known that because they
got that they have money
but it's not like a man's going on like
anything imagine it's not going we're
not going to openly say oh we're going
to the dinner table the bill comes oh
you know I can't afford this but someone
might have never been in the situation
yeah you're never gonna be in that I've
never been so I can't relate what's your
name royal royal you're never going to
be in that situation where a man's going
to be on the table I've had one guy say
to me that like go for coffee and you
know he's he I think he's I think he was
testing me but I was fine with that
because I actually liked him like it's
not an issue
no he never but he said that you know
I'm not in a great position right now
and that's fine because I knew he was
intelligent and I knew that he was
someone I could build with because he's
very smart he just wasn't in the right
place at the time no I didn't have an
issue that unfortunately it didn't work
out why did it work out well he's he's
not believe me
bro it's not about money like I I'm not
a shallow person so please let's not do
that but I know we're just repeating
back what you're saying I'm speaking
from my own experience so far I can't
say anything else but there could have
been at least I've never had a man that
that's not been able to pay for
something that he's I'm aware of and he
has I've never had that that you're
aware of there could have been at least
one man that took you on that date that
was the last time probably yeah and I
would never have knew so and I'm
concerned
I do respect that but I I think if you
think broke man shouldn't date then
should or then should fat women not date
Beauty
is an eye of the beholder period so
there's a guy that might know money
isn't it money is in the eye of the
beholder
um listen money money is in the eyes
listen if if you have if your mentality
is above average and you're broke I [__]
with you because I know you got
potential and that we can build together
we can be powerful what is potential
it's money later like that's all it is
Essentials money later it's more about
their life just go ahead okay if you
miss bro if you meet Brokey at 25 and
you're with him for five years he's
still broke he unemployed what you're
saying say that again sorry broke you
mean a broken guy 25 and he's unemployed
and now now um he's 30. um you're still
with him he's unemployed are you staying
or going uh no because you're not
pushing me to my limit no I wouldn't
well five of you wouldn't write up five
years if he is unemployed and broke for
five years and doesn't want to make a
move how long does it take to create a
proper business and be successful in
life
not doing nothing
okay I forgot it was unemployed for five
years
I'm with you but my my point is you're
you're lying like it's lying yeah you're
just lying because you're like oh if he
has the right mentality I don't care
about money okay but I said like all the
ambition translates to his money later
so when women say oh I don't care about
money yes it does because because women
women do leave if the men don't make
enough money if women outer in the men
they leave the average woman but I feel
like the average woman will leave but
you are the average woman I mean the
average mindset woman the average
mindset you have them no I don't
and everyone tells
okay what makes you different because I
I'm just I feel like I'm very deep and
um I've just learned I've really taken
that time out to study life and to
understand how life is I'm 32 now okay
eight last month so I feel like I've
taken time out from in to go inwards and
to learn about life and to just you know
be more not logical but be more um on
point I don't know how to explain it but
I don't think my mindset is average I
don't think I will ever be average and I
really believe in myself okay you're 100
average you're a comedian no she's a
comedian though no no no look at me look
in the Dead series
and that's not an insult I think I have
an average check I don't think yeah
because I even said before I came on the
show she's she's a badass like she's
built all this let's see you're lying
again didn't I say that to you I've been
talking about that stuff before I met
you but I'm saying like the way you
speak all right okay and I'm telling you
I've met women with a top 10 percent 20
do you know how many women I speak to
hundreds hundreds and I'm saying like
I've met women with the top ten twenty
percent Minds I'm not saying it's
horrible but I'm saying an average chick
when it comes to mindset do you know
what I think I just like I think money's
not I don't think money is important so
it's nothing to me but see you've
contradicted yourself like 20 times in
this conversation it's very chaotic to
like speak to you like it's very chaotic
because I don't really understand what
you're saying okay because in one hand
you kind of we're speaking down to the
men in the room because they don't want
to spend 200 pounds on a date then
you're saying money is nothing do you
see how that's confusing nothing so
paying too much what is that that I
don't that's fine okay it's not it's
nothing
appreciate it and I do but it's not it's
not I don't think about it because money
is money it just is what it is because
you don't have it I mean okay okay
I understand
I understand what you're saying I just
don't think you understand how it sounds
and it sounds really unappreciative
because
you spend every night on dinner on
yourself me I spend a lot of money every
night no no I can't why because that's
irresponsible
I've had a long-term relationship where
we live together but I've never relied
on a man for anything in my whole entire
life so so it cares your question okay
so all right you've you've never been
proposed to not really not like that no
okay okay so if you were if you had this
amazing mindset you're 32 you have kids
no okay so do you know what your chances
below 50 of having a child possibly but
if you're if you're single at 30 your
chance is like 40 of having a kid so
you're more likely to never have
children and at 30 and at 32 that means
you're three years away from geriatric
pregnancy wow like so that means if
you're single today you got to find a
guy in 3 years to agree to marry you
um and agree to get in a long-term
relationship marry you and then have a
kid or just get pregnant
so so the odd so physically right right
statistically okay okay okay
so so and based off of like the so the
last you've been dating since what
you're 18. no well yeah okay so so 10 12
to 14 years you've been unsuccessful
well
right yeah so if you're single right and
I'm not claiming to be the all like I
know everything but I'm saying how how
can you say you're in the top like you
have this amazing mindset if no men have
picked your mindset and it's not looks
you're pretty my mindset changed at 20
at age 28 so before that I was a
different person four years ago okay so
you've got four years to try out this
mindset
and okay I've been going free stuff okay
so and you've been acute you've been
going through things so you've been
accumulating Trump relationship kind of
whatever where you were problematic
till this day so I must not have been
that oh no okay for sex and like I don't
think you realize
I'm not either have sex I'm really
really okay did he have sex with you not
not straight away no did he did he ever
have sex with you yeah
okay
okay no no no I'm telling you girl this
is how guys see it like I've talked to
so many dudes if they've had sex with
you once
maybe he liked having sex with you okay
yeah cause my pussy's tight
[Laughter]
can I just say it wouldn't take three
months to come to a decision on this one
and you're so lovely honestly you have
so much going for you I really like you
thank you don't say things like that
keep it for yourself you know I'm
playing around
I don't think you understand okay okay
how is a husband gonna hear that yeah
you just don't put your chances even
more yeah
I'm genuinely trying to help you I'm
trying to help you so seriously so like
those are fake eyelashes yeah do you
know do you know what those stand for do
you know what the history of those are
it's literally what hookers used to use
to keep calm out of their eyes I could
probably believe that yeah yeah sure
okay okay okay so and when men see that
they like hoop earrings that signal yeah
yeah and the ears aren't too bad but but
I'm saying when you're saying like my
tight like is that what you want your
wife and the mother of your kids to see
but the thing is I'm just a funny person
like I'm really outspoken and I know I'm
I'm a focus I like to think I'm funny
you know a comedian but like there's
some things that you really shouldn't
say publicly if you want to be taken
seriously from a guy I think that um
you know if it's meant to be it's meant
to be he's out there somewhere and he'll
appreciate it do you think I'm broke do
you think a broke fat guy should say oh
if it's meant to be women will like me
or do you think he should improve I
personally would definitely improve but
okay yeah okay so if you're if your
mindset is off do you think we say it's
meant if it's meant to be it's meant to
be or do we try to improve always try to
improve so so how do we improve as women
if we can't even admit there's a problem
right and so right now it's like it's
like you're kind of living in in
delusion everyone's like you know maybe
it's not a good look and you're like
well it's just how I am but I feel like
me saying my pussy's tight it isn't
determine it isn't determine how many
men I've slept with if I'm a hoe do I go
out and suck dick every week
I wanna hear from them what do you hey
blessing
laughing as a guy you're out to your
more traditional guy you want to be
married right bring me in this one all
right all right what do you what do you
what do you think when a woman says that
canceled okay
[Music]
but the thing is if guys if guys see
signals that you're a hoe they're not
going to investigate to find out they're
just going to think how how like they're
not gonna go and do these deep dot like
no they're just gonna they're just gonna
write you I agree with that but I think
it takes an individual to take time to
actually get to know the person see if
they really like that okay but the men
you want don't have time because they're
working what happened to waiting for
marriage like where did that go in all
of this conversation wait wait for
imagine what I'm sorry where did that
where did waiting for marriage come in
this conversation like where did that go
like why did that leave the world
uh women yeah why because I think women
because well because I think women we're
in control of the like sex so we're in
control of the Chastity of the sexual
Marketplace I think virgins have a hard
time nowadays because like one
why would a man wait for a woman that's
not a virgin
they wouldn't so and the problem I think
that virgins are going to have is how
does he know she's a virgin with how
much women lie nowadays yeah and how
does he know like even if he he gets a
virgin and this I've spoken to guys with
this like about Virgin and I'm not
saying guys don't want it but I think
it's more difficult because of the
marketplace because even if you get a
virgin like she could still go on social
media and leave but I still think it's a
valuable value to have and I think I
agree with somebody to marry them then
you should like just wait simply that's
that that's why they believe do you
think that so what about the women that
okay so again the average woman here
one out of three women has an STD one
out of three women's have an abortion do
you think they should say we're going to
wait till marriage
I mean I think they should stop doing
what they're doing because they're
they're if they keep doing that they are
going to further their likeliness of not
getting a man not being married not
having kids and being miserable no and
it's hard because it's like part of me
agrees with you I think it's idealistic
but I think like telling a single mother
wait till you're married good luck I
mean that's that's a girl that slept
with like 20 dudes good luck stop at
least stop because if you're gonna keep
sleeping with dudes you're gonna when
you're 30 you're gonna be like 100 guys
you know so at least stop now and I
think it comes from Family Values like
how you're raised you didn't raise me
that way I know that's what's so
shocking before when I told my
grandmother I was marrying your dad she
was like well I hope you've slept with
him and I was shocked because she was a
hardcore Christian and her upbringing
was in the church 100 but she's like if
you don't know then you know you could
be getting yourself into trouble yeah I
know I'm not saying that was right but I
was shocked when she said that I just
think like from a guy's point of view
like if a girl's not a virgin like a guy
shouldn't wait I like I think like why
would a guy so I think that's the tough
thing like for those women it's like
well what are they like what you're
gonna because I I think a guy that does
that as a simp to be honest if she's not
a virgin
you're gonna you're gonna buy a used car
for new prices yeah no and I'm in a
relationship that's saying to Mary and
we're waiting for marriage and I think
oh that's so cute I think that's a
beautiful thing and I just want more
women to fall into that role fall into
that that place because it's such a
beautiful thing to have with somebody
and to sleep with 20 guys and 50 guys
and say like my is tight like that's not
cute like what is not what do you think
what do you think of the women that say
you're missing out like you just need to
see what's out there missing out on what
getting drunk and like having with a
bunch of guys and like like my body's a
temple like my body is precious anything
that goes on it or in it is very like it
has to be pure I believe in Purity and
if it's not pure it's not right I agree
so you don't mind so your mind's a
virgin right now
I'm not gonna say like but that's like
very personal but
but the problem about this about this
conversation so obviously that's my
answer
the pure thing yes you can't be pure and
my partner are pure well both virgins in
because that's the definition of pure
Clarity just give Clarity
that means nothing has touched your body
your body
is pure that means nobody can touch you
none of YouTube I'm not gonna expose his
life okay
um
where were we in the freaking all right
hold on sorry oh super thank you for
reminding me blessing
um guys guys guys make sure you like the
video subscribe to the channel and also
um let's see
we're gonna go to the supers
1000 likes we need 1 000 likes you know
yeah a thousand likes to open the chat
oh we're so close 765. guys guys
these the by the way I have these
opinions do not reflect me uh but when
people give me money I will read them
all right black Moses um she's acting
very childish she refuses to grow up
return back to the streets where she
belongs Josh depends how many
opportunities we've had relationships
for real I respect her after three um
done after two if you're not attractive
I'll wait after three if she's a good
woman I'll just wait for her
Dee I love how you ask the right
questions and they just telling
themselves black top man I'm 32 and 35
I'm embarrassed for you please stop
Josh depending on how many um
opportunities we have relations for real
for real I respect her after three I
think you sent the same one twice it
done after two if you're not attractive
I'll rate for wait for three if she's a
good woman just wait for her Dion c um
Royal please remove all that makeup I
bet you are a four out of ten um you are
in the wall
um guys remember it has to be over five
dollar Super Chat in order for me to
read it uh Royal needs to go back to the
streets can't fix all of that
um Sani um it's 200 isn't a not you're a
lot you're not even worth 20. uh bright
and two weeks two weeks I'm I'm taking
into account her actions which will give
a hint to body count and then I'll ask
around and no I'll ask and know her body
count uh Lawrence um woman with the
eight tattoos is giving off narcissism
Vibe like she's never the problem if the
relationship doesn't work out um
Hiroshima can you stop gaslighting
except uh the the men you want only use
you for a booty call stop saying I don't
want anyone nah just pump and dump oh
not gonna lie
um right pure pure um Miss Shogun chaos
uh full we tied of the body positivity
movement exists to make money off of
women because big girls get money too
you don't see any plus-sized male models
Doug MPA uh Pearl please list the uh the
other things that high value men don't
want in women remember you came up with
on a live a couple months ago I will re
that is my favorite list to read okay uh
Scout and Bradley being submissive
doesn't mean do whatever I say but
listening and not fighting to everything
Southern Bells do this can't wait to see
Pearl on on apologetic uh trigger
statistically after the age of 65 the
percentage of obese people drops
drastically because they die Glenn
Lawrence all men need to do is uh roll
up read Rolo's uh the message is the
median blog or all men need to do is
read Rolos the median is the message
blog post then see if her words and
actions match interracial relationships
for black men we value Community for
black men Community we value bigger
women because they make for better oh I
read that already uh Let me refresh it
really quick
uh let me double check what how many
likes are we at blessing
900 guys 100 more likes
uh black Moses she's acting very
childish she already read that already
uh boy five dollars you think I'm made
of money well you said two so you're
halfway there you know
um okay guys I'm gonna find this uh uh
Google doc a couple months ago I've made
a list of the things that us as women
should stop doing
now this is not to say that I am perfect
and I've never said anything on this
list
um however
I just felt like this was a very very
good list
um so this is the things that men uh
look for basically or don't want it's
like want don't want kind of a
combination no top tattoos your hobbies
cannot be going to the bar every weekend
and going out all the time looking like
a hoe no heavy makeup eyelash extensions
no super heavy eyeliner no shopping
addiction no piercing except ears be
ready be able to get ready in 30 minutes
or less no super long fingernails do not
be an idiot do not be a beautiful
Majestic creature a girl she has to have
a fitness routine good with kid knows
how to cook coachable teachable feminine
do not be a feminist men want women that
work hard but not too hard and at the
right things they do not want a girl
that wants a career more than a family
this is my favorite one the words we're
gonna stop saying wow partner horoscope
signs looking for a connection energy
trauma toxic masculinity my truth
healing my narcissistic ex-boyfriend my
abusive ex-boyfriend grape accusations
don't judge yeah but manifesting equals
I want to do no work and still get the
outcome I want as a woman we know you're
a woman I did too much and I let him
walk all over me equals I like cheaters
and toxic men and I will choose them and
be toxic as well and not admit my part
that I had any part to play except quote
unquote giving too much generational
trauma I make the same mistakes that my
parents make and I'm too dumb to learn
from their mistakes and instead I will
make the same mistakes but blame it on
them I'm in my feminine energy men
always stare and approach me I will be
submissive for the right man men are
trash equals I take no accountability
for the negative part that myself or any
women play in relationships he needs to
make six figures equals I have no
emphasis emphasis on character I don't
need a man but I want to win my ring
costs this much Financial abuse I became
feminine I need a man to maintain you we
need to Vibe I feel like I'm a
traditional when I am single Manish I
will be submissive for the right man who
hurt you internalized misogyny I'm
leveling up altogether I need a man to
be on my level I'm a boss babe I'm a bad
[__] these men are broke and dusties I
am the table I am a 10. he needs to add
to what I have going on in my life not
all women equals that is a problem with
women but I won't admit it's a problem
um
I need someone to match my energy
um I still don't really know what that
means
um I am his peace a broken men uh men
are F boys my body my choice he hit me
harder than I hit him body positivity uh
manifest I am not fat I am plus size or
thick small D energy my ex was a
narcissist I am a queen who hurt you no
respect for my own mother yeah I mean
how is that those are all the words that
you can't say yeah what can we say then
I have a list don't worry I'm I'm so
here to help
all right and this is collaborative so
if you guys have anything you want to
add to it you know feel free phrases to
add I trust you I support you whatever
you say honey thank you I have your back
I'm making this for dinner tonight I
believe or I think what can I do for you
how can I help I'm proud of you I
believe in you I couldn't do this
without you you I need you I love you I
miss you I care about you I want you I
admire you oh gosh I always forget this
one's I'm not reading that uh you
inspired me
read that I do this I hate reading this
one um get in the bedroom and drop your
pants before you go to work uh you
inspire me huh
thank you for working so hard um babe I
know you didn't mean it I'll let it go
it's not a big deal I love that I love
that
you know we can add more a few things
you want to add to it's really
collaborative I've worked with a lot of
people on this okay cool I think that
whatever you say honey you want a head
massage that's the only thing that
depends on the context exactly and I was
thinking as well yes it can be a little
bit like oh you know like oh I have to
do it again I just you know you you it
depends on the content where the good
women are gone
if you're with the white woman that you
that won't happen if you're with the
white Roman if you're with the right man
that won't happen
it depends on the context she's right it
does but it doesn't matter okay I have
to be honest I think women that say this
because I hear this a lot it typically
means I am disagreeable and I don't want
to listen come on okay typically and or
the men I pick aren't worthy or like
something like I like bombs basically is
the other one like it's like well some
some women pick men who are I think for
their character to mask I don't want to
say that because then you're going to be
like feminine no like two you know like
she feminine enough the man is really
masculine she's in her feminine most of
the time but sometimes she's like see I
see the language in her feminine yeah I
knew you're gonna pick that up
I just think it's like nonsense like
it's just it's like these women that go
on Instagram and they'll say oh I'm a
feminine I don't know if it's you I hope
that's not what you do but but like it's
like I'm now a femininity coach and
there's some genuine ones I'm not gonna
say there's not there are genuine ones
that do this too masculine feminine
energy
the ones that I see that are full of
[__] because Men actually look to solve
problems so if you look at like men's
Improvement it's very practical so it's
very much like go to the gym screw a
bunch of girls so you know how to or do
you know like even there's X corn star
that's been on my show he has very
practical you know tips not my thing
right but like and or they'll do
um like go to the gym make more money
women it's very like broad like like
soft life I'm gonna sit at home
um and it's never like concrete steps
I've only had one like femininity coach
give me like real concrete steps that
isn't just like journaling or
say about uh feminine feminine feminine
coaches
um they operate from
um
again energy but like what is to be
feminine they tell you be creative like
focus on things that make you tap into
the womb like that traditional woman
that's what they are all about like try
to for I've I've been in touch with some
of them they tell you like listen to
music dance or create something uh with
uh like a painting or something uh
tangible with like artistic yeah um and
to me this sounds like nothing useful to
a guy
go listen to some music
like I'm just I just said yeah there's
only been one femininity coach that like
actually talked about real stuff and she
helped me write most of these like words
to add in the short term it might seem
that it's not helping but imagine on the
long term rather than a woman being in
her as I say masculine energy which is
like shouting and confronting she learns
to be submissive but like step by step
first of all by tapping into these
skills then to to be comfortable just
doing uh even something such as cooking
they tell you cooking makes you tap into
your feminine energy more and more so
maybe by building those little little
habits uh I think cooking I guess I
don't think cooking is bad but
I just
you can't convince me do you know why
why we need these now we I agree with
you I agree that it shouldn't matter but
we need this now because a lot of women
and men as well for god that Natural
State you know what's your natural state
as a woman I don't know because I get
really confused because I hear these
like women talk about soft life right
but like our great-grandmothers really
didn't have a soft life they were milky
like at least in the U.S they're milking
cows like have you seen Amish people
that's where they used to live like they
do not have a soft life and soft life to
me is living off a man that's what I see
as a soft lie maybe yeah when you ask
where all the women good women went I
mean to me they went to confusion and
Independence and this confusion is is a
diffused awareness because the Primal
nature right A man is hunting he's
directive in his Focus
and a woman is diffused because she only
has a certain amount of daylight hours
to get as many berries as she can and
she's very skilled at it she can do it
way quicker than a man apparently and as
part of our survival mechanism and so it
is kind of obtuse and Broad when we
think about how we go back into our
feminine nature so we're not you know in
this CEO role of our families of our
relationships of our businesses and then
we got to come home and then deal with
the reality of like you know being a
partner which is a totally different
energy it's not you're not directive
yeah you got to get the meal on the
table and my grandmother my mother they
worked really hard as Homemakers it was
like taboo for them to work yeah but my
generation and our generation now it's
very it's a lot of confusion and we're
still growing into that you know how do
we balance that just beyond faithful
I'm being serious she made a Triple
Single Ladies all of these things with a
ring on her finger
I think we're very capable you know what
I'm saying there's a lot of confusion
about being from the night to be honest
you'll say you're right from the 90s
2000s whatever there's been there's been
a lot of Independence Independence do
your thing blah blah blah blah blah cool
you can do your Independence but if you
don't need a man
someone said modern day Gathering has
turned into shopping
but why do you think women are having
burnout endocrine disruption cancer
depression I mean there's all these
issues with women's health because
they're trying to be um
like a hormone doctor about this he said
like high strike women and men don't
handle stress the same and it really
messes up our hormones being like high
stress positions and you know what the
medicine if you stay in your feminine
energy and you come home and you look
after your partner your man is going to
want to look after and do everything in
his power to make sure you're good yeah
that's as simple as I can explain it
like as long as you stay in your family
and you look after that man he's going
to do everything for you regardless
naturally but earlier with what I was
saying if you're not showing certain
things to him he's going to see that all
right cool she's not really mankind I'll
sit back I'm there but I'll sit back a
little bit but if he sees you're making
effort like like even cooking cooking if
you want when I get through to a man's
heart is through his belly 100 as simple
as that did you get what I'm saying yeah
and I also I fell into the boss babe
culture for a long time when I was obese
and I and then I started losing weight
but I was still in the boss baby culture
I was like oh I don't need a man like
I'm fine and it was when I had the daddy
issues when I was I didn't have a good
relationship with my father and it
wasn't until I hit my relationship with
my father that I was like oh okay I
actually you know it's really important
that I I don't have to work like a man I
was so stressed I was so anxious all the
time and then I just let it go it's like
I don't need to do that my future
husband will provide for me my future
husband will do these and I'll fall into
my feminine roles I will cook I will
clean I will take care of the kids I'll
take care of the house like that and
I'll go I'll Garden what did you do did
you quit your job no I just okay I was
just curious well I guess I did it's a
little miracle I just I flipped two
houses last year and I was like I don't
want to do this anymore so I just
decided to stop doing it that's cool it
was a miracle though really yeah because
no because I was the boss right I had to
be ever the provider I had to be
everything and you didn't have that
example and I think that's another part
of where all the good women of God
inside of this Independence inside of
this confusion it's fatherless families
and like Pearl was saying earlier if you
don't have the example how are you
supposed to know and you haven't had the
example Penelope so it's a miracle
purely purely yeah no it is and it was
it was like growing up with you as my
mom like you played both roles the dad
and the mom and so that was very
interesting because I grew up thinking
oh I I don't need men like men are
terrible and I even thought my father
was terrible because now he's like my
best friend but I think where the good
women are going is they think that it's
a bad thing to be feminine I think that
that the mindset of women today feel
like
um and now if you're feminine and
traditional online people are like
you're you know you're not a feminist
you hate women you are terrible you are
a disgraceful Society you should go die
and it's like wait wait what like women
are the most beautiful things on the
planet they create human
create human being why are women putting
putting women want women to fail
we're not supposed to be competing with
our moms generation because the thing is
like if you have a 45 year old and you
have like a 25 year old girl it's like
you a lot of times the guys you might
want are the same age because women like
45 tend to want guys like it's like five
to seven years younger where women
um 25 want guys five to seven years
older this crossover and I think bitter
older women that don't want you to win
will tell you the wrong information
that's true and and it's because like if
they're if they're being a hoe right
like what's the worst feeling when you
take a test and you fail what's the
worst feeling when everyone else
succeeded yeah right but if you turn
around and they say I failed too it's
like you feel a little bit better so
it's like these women want other people
to be miserable in their negative
decisions
of people because of it because of
succeeding in in my relationship and
having a healthy relationship with my
father people dislike me because of that
and it's like why do you hate me for
having a healthy relationship with my
family am I am I so would you would you
say sound like they don't want you to
win
know that you've been divorced miserable
sad fat on your phone on Tick Tock dying
so would you say yeah this is like
technically just a woman's problem then
because it's women that it's not
technically men that put down women you
know it's women that put down women the
woman trying to be men hurt are hurting
the the feminine not not the feminine
the beta men right they're that that's
hurting beta man that's why we have
betamen it's because of the masculine
well I think it becomes a problem
because you have 80 percent of women
screw in 20 of men so then women don't
respect the average guy I did a show the
other day and like most women said they
wouldn't date a bus driver
that they're above a bus for our average
checks and it's why you have average
chicks saying they're at the level of a
celebrity no offense but like it's like
you have average chicks thinking they're
they're so great when it's like
literally you are average your average
looking even average mindset most people
are average and men will accept this but
women won't it's like an insult for us
to be normal so then you you won't see
normal women dating normal men like do
you feel like that that is because
social media has a lot to play for it
they feel like there's a lot more I
think it's a social I think it's social
media and dating apps they go they feel
like they've got more accessibility to
hire people I mean they do like because
the issue nowadays because this is what
made me think about this I'm like how
would you find a good woman and I was
thinking about this and I made a chart
and I had like the body count of a woman
on one hand and I had the looks of a
woman on a one hand and so I was like a
woman that's eight to ten with a high or
a low body count good luck keeping her
do you know what the list is gonna be
for a girl that that's like that hot
with like like the competition is crazy
crazy and so it's like you could be
dating a woman and if there's High
competition for a drink could slide in
your girl's DM 100 or maybe it's not
Drake it's the town whoever right and
then I was thinking about it and I was
like unless a guy sleeps with a lot of
women how is he going to know the
difference between a woman that's been
out with everybody and a girl that does
it has it they never did they can't no
they can't know unless they've been with
a lot of girls and I'm like it's kind of
unfortunate because it's like the only
solution for the men seems to be to
sleep around which I don't think is you
know great for society but it's like
it's women's fault because we're the
ones doing the sleeping do you think
that men should have more than one woman
I
um I I think that it's silly to date
certain men and expect monogamy so I
think it's silly to date say Jason
Derulo Chris Brown These are extreme
examples but there's certain men that
it's very silly to expect it because
he's never been monogamous and they
never will be I think monogamy in
general is better for a society I forget
to sit the higher I'm even talking on
average men no more men on a day today
because obviously you said earlier on
that there's more women under Earth than
men yeah so on average how we are
naturally
do you think that the average man should
have one woman
um I think that it's better for society
if monogamy is better because you get
like a growing
um having a lot of sex sexless men like
usually causes Society to collapse
um so I think monogamy is better by and
large but I think that a certain
percentage of men are always going to be
non-monogamous
um and that's kind of the way it's been
the last like two million years because
85 it's like the last
I don't want to say the how long it's
been like this because I don't remember
off the top of my head but I know like
historically they always it seems like
all of society has been non-monogamous
because 17 men reproduce for every uh
one 17 women reproduced for every one
man like 8 000 years ago and on top of
that there's like two women have always
reproduced for every one man but it's
actually um or 40 of men have never
reproduced forty percent of men I'm
sorry I'm butchering this but but the 85
of um like 85 percent of society has
generally been monogamous were the top
15 percent of men have just been like
slaying is it yeah well okay you do a
lot of stats here yeah I know a lot of
average men out here that's probably not
on these stats doing the same thing and
and when I say a lot I'm talking if
you're just talking average men in
London obviously London I don't know
about America average and what in
sleeping with a lot of women no like
average looks average money would you
average looks average average job I'm
I'm I can even give you examples of a
few average men that are big in weight
and just got no more jobs that aren't
dealing with a lot of women across the
board
um well there's a couple things so I
mean typically again like there's been
studies on dating apps and in in person
where women find 80 of men is ugly not
okay not average they think ugly he is
unattractive ugly would you say the top
the same on these dating apps
um yeah maybe yeah I don't know I don't
I don't believe so um
I think that I think that if you look at
the numbers social media is the number
one way people are meeting 100 so are
social media and dating apps and like
when you look at so then the question is
if that's where people are meeting what
do the numbers look like in the dating
apps well women only swipe right five
percent of the time so that means on the
number one way people are meeting we're
sharing men 100 because there's always
going to be three men because we're the
hunters so we wait 100 wait say say that
again it's always going to be men
because we're the hunters we're always
going we're going to be the higher
anyway do you know what I'm saying yeah
but when you're saying the average men
that get women they probably get women
over the age of 30. because women tend
to go for looks and so in their 20s I
fully agree with yeah you know I agree
with that because I feel like we're
single mothers
between 20 and 30 women are very
selective in what they do and then when
they get to the end you started reading
off a lot of stats about yeah pregnancy
Dairy actually yeah when they start
realizing that and they go for the
average they feel like they can come
back to that agreement or even go back
to man that they was that was trying to
get them when they were 18 19 and feel
like they can go back to them but
obviously with men it's a bit different
because men yeah at 30 we start peaking
we get correct yeah so we start it's
changed there's a change you get what
I'm saying yeah yeah and so that's why I
say women pick non-monogamy in their 20s
when they have the most leverage yeah
and they pick the 20 of men then in
their 30s they we tend to pick
um like the rest basically and so the
issue is like when when women cheat who
do they typically cheat with you guys
know anyone
and X's correct 100 correct so the issue
that a lot of these guys are getting
into and this is why guys don't like
typically like a lot of guys will say I
don't date women over 30 and it's not a
looks thing it's that if she's 30 like
how many relationships has she had is
one of those guys better than me and
does she want to be with him and the
odds are he probably is because in her
20s she had more lovers in her 30s so
what are the odds in her 30s she can get
a better rather than in her 20s likely
right and he was probably top 20 percent
alone slightly when they have that
relationship from 20 to 30 there's
there's always that one guy that can
always come back in the background
I've spoken to women that have had like
I don't know six year situation chips on
and off were between every relationship
and that's like how they keep their like
body count low or whatever it's like a
say so they'll like go back to the lat
and it kind of so it kind of makes sense
in your body count like 100 but you
don't have to do that you can just use
the toys
you know everyone gotta come off yeah
but they are usually usually the guys
are the ones that are on standby they're
waiting and you know why men will always
be honest and I know what they want I'm
not saying that I'm fooled but and you
know why it works we're always there you
know why it works for women and men will
always be there because men don't talk
to me but I'm not gonna go to to Ted and
like yo Ted dealing with power you know
boom boom boom whereas and women always
want to go to women about stuff yeah so
yeah you look in terms of you can always
have your exes there because my man will
just wait in the in the background the
Shadows
when you're done when
now she won't be the main one she want
to go to the the main woman and tell her
yo we've been together
I'm gonna read this was a I think this
is like a 50 I don't know the conversion
but Pearl listen all these discussions
are pointless walk outside and you will
see the majority of men don't leave
their homes this phenomenon first
started in Japan we are just a few years
behind I went to Japan and all I see is
women outside my main point is you
cannot bring back most men outside of
their rooms if you have to waste time
arguing debating with modern women
Society will collapse just like Japan
women will say it's expensive to have
kids T he he children
um but men are indoors with corn or what
is what is it what is he implying
um
I don't know to be honest I just read it
um I mean I think in general people
aren't leaving and especially like now
they're gonna have ai and like I think
there's just more people aren't going
outside it's this main point
um but I was I was thinking about this
the other today because I was like if I
was a guy how would you pick a good
because I've been interviewing men for
this divorce documentary I'm doing so I
interviewed the men that have been like
stupid wrecked by divorced okay so
they're um
and typically this happens like it's
this is kind of the story that I've
heard like from guys typically he meets
her and there's like an unplanned
pregnancy
and typically like they get married
pretty quick and then
um she'll go to a women's shelter like
accuse him of abuse on some level when
some like they'll even prove that she
was lying because you get a free lawyer
here if you accuse a guy of abuse
and basically they have their whole
lives ruined they're on these really big
child support payments like one guy lost
his job like it's really really sad like
I listen like there and you can just
tell they're like a shell of a dude who
they used to be right and I'll speak to
these men and I'm like okay so she and
some the girls had red flags but some
it's like she was from a two-parent home
um she there's there's one that's in the
news right now where they're both
virgins on their wedding night I'll see
another that's like she um
she came from a Christian family she was
from Eastern Europe and like all the
like on paper and I'm like I don't know
as a guy how you avoid that
and so that's that's why I did this show
is I was genuinely asking how do you
like what what where are the good women
and how do men pick them
and right now I'll tell you what we've
got
um hold on I have the list
um go on a coffee date before or after
easily
sleep with her as soon as possible
um one month to a year ask her to make
coffee ask to cook on the spot take her
on a coffee date date as many women as
possible to tell the difference make
sure you're not on birth control what
does her relationship look like with her
dad and I don't even say this to like
harp on women right because like men
have issues women of issues but I just
think like with how much guys I have to
lose I'm like how I can't even think of
how you avoid it well I would say like
just don't don't sign a contract when
you get married just get married and
don't sign the contract I fought this
too I thought exactly like you
but no it doesn't matter because when
you have a kid that's true but I think
if there was more Purity in the world I
think if if men and women were both
seeking more Purity from each other like
how how honest are you being right now
you know how how gentle are you as a
pure person do you want to harm people
do you want to do you go out of your way
to lie let's okay let's follow this
let's say the guy says I'm going to be
as pure as possible I'm gonna have as
little experience with women as possible
how does he tell the difference between
a woman with a high body count and a low
body count if he has no experience with
women there's no way no no there's no
there really is no way right so
if he has if he has known factual ways I
know what I'm saying okay I would think
you'd have to like kind of be with a lot
of women to figure that out but if he
doesn't want to if he follows the Purity
route
it's that men still have to date women I
think men and women should should date
men a few men and women at least to see
like see what see what people are out
there to know the difference between
different people and also yeah observing
other people's relationships is
important but I don't think you have to
sleep with somebody too know if somebody
is a is wifey material you know I don't
think you have to sleep with someone
yeah being like intimate having intimate
conversations having a relationship you
know having your Traditional Values play
out in life roles you know cooking and
cleaning and taking care of the house
whatever I think those are things those
are important things to do and that's
how you'll know if that's a woman you
actually want to marry one day but
that's very pure right there is no like
you know having the Intercourse and
making out right but I guess my question
is like the average woman and like we
could talk about like what we should do
and this is where like it's hard because
I used to think like this I used to
think like you but it's like I think
we're like red pill and like Trad cons
tend to like talk past each other where
it's like the average woman to slept
with five to eight people
like why would he wait for a woman
that's no like so defensive right I
agree with this and like they should not
a man should not wait for someone who
slept this five nine woman right and so
how would he tell the difference between
a virgin who's lying and a girl who's at
like actually a virgin unless he's carry
themselves I mean like you might you
won't know you won't you will never know
right sure I I agree with you you'll
never know for sure but the but the way
a woman carries herself really shows a
lot about who she is and if she's gonna
lie about something or not yeah and what
yeah that's a practical solution I like
that and how she responds to difficult
situations that's a good one yeah that's
a really good one because that that'll
be the test every time yeah go on a
camping trip or travel with them or do
something that's you know challenging or
out of their country and this is the
hard thing I keep thinking to these men
I was in the document like I did the
documentary with and a lot of them did
this stuff and that's why I'm genuinely
like I think there's like there's no way
you could know like genuinely you could
never you could never know 100 sure yeah
well you can you can get you can engage
because through conversation me news
having a conversation and I find out
okay how much relationships you if
you've been in a relationship 10 years
one person yet you could have done what
you're doing yeah but then I can gauge
between this agent okay you've had one
person right that maybe you've been
outside for the last two years did you
get what I'm saying I think you can
gauge it and you will never know exact
number because she could be doing other
things and we're religion and
spiritually definitely pays a part in
who you choose and how you act right
because if you both have a similar
religion or spirituality okay okay so so
then why are the reputation of church
women so bad
church and they do Terrible Things yes
right right but I'm saying like the
reputation of church women is best worse
than the normal population yes and so
it's like just church right no but but
it's like it's it's just crazy because
it's like everything we tell them to
look for it's like
yeah because they go and commit sins
they can wash them away on the Sunday
and I think men and women both do that
you know they both do that
sounds like for women it's it's also
pretty destructive because their chances
of getting another guy is pretty low it
sounds like well it's decimating it
totally destroys both of their lives it
sounds like when it doesn't work out not
only the man's life but also the woman's
life because she doesn't have that many
chances afterwards according to the
statistics you've been sharing but you
know I don't think this is a man issue
though I feel like it's women that need
to understand men more and understand
what men want if they understand what
men want they won't have the issue of
finding another it's actually quite
simple isn't it I just I don't think
women would leave if they didn't think
they could do better yeah like nobody
nobody leaves to like be alone I'm not
saying they can't like we're delusional
you know but what's better because they
might think that guy's better but well I
mean a lot of times it's like the we
have imaginations for example a man
could do way more for you but it's about
what you accepted he couldn't give you
everything you want to make sure you're
the number one woman but if he goes out
and he's got a couple gallon cheating or
whatever are you gonna accept that for
being a happy wife of course not well no
one would no a lot of people do exactly
a lot of people
if he looks
make sure you're good everything at home
is patterned you're the number one woman
but yes he goes out sometimes and he's
he goes on weekenders away let's say and
he sleeps with women but when he comes
back
the house is patterned everything's
looked after there's just something
wrong with his values there's something
definitely his connection to God or
religion or something there's something
wrong with his values but what about her
what about maybe she did something to
make him cheat and she don't know about
you I always feel like there's reasons
people cheat always like men don't cheat
for no reason and women don't cheat but
like I just think we kind of get it I
think we get in this like like if a guy
cheats he's like the worst like people
always misconstrue my thought I don't
think cheating is good but like it's
like we'll demonize the men for cheating
right but when women go into
relationships with open social media
accounts and we don't demonize them
where they can still get attention from
high value men exactly 100 and it's like
we don't it's the same thing but yet
like if a guy cheats it's the worst
thing ever no I think it's both equally
I feel like if a female cheese they're
demon is the worst thing ever and that
man will never take her back so I think
it's the opposite I think that's what's
taken back that's not true when you
think about it like men marry single
mothers all the time
and in a way that's like I mean you're
coming in with another man's kid
I hate what you're saying to a certain
degree man yeah because obviously if
you're letting someone inside your body
that man is going to look at you
differently yeah no no no forget the man
looking at he's going to look at you
differently I'm saying if you're opening
your dead
I don't think you're just going to open
your legs to a man just just off the rip
at night I do think I do think people
should try to work out cheating though
like I like I I think like it's about
the kids it's not about you you should
try to work it out yeah yeah you should
work at 100 like no offense people
watching this but like they my mom and
dad got divorced when I was four and it
was because my dad cheated on her and I
don't think anyone should you know I
think cheating I don't inherently think
cheating is a good thing but I think I
sometimes wonder what would my life have
looked like had they been together I
wonder that every day how would I have
been you know I'm I'm grateful that I
know I am the way I am now but I'm just
saying like I know there's a lot of
girls out there who have dysfunctional
families and don't have a father and
mother that are together and I've seen
people with who have their mother and
father together and they're very
different people the way they approach
themselves the way they talk to people
the way they react to situations they're
just different people and I think that's
beautiful and so like that's even like a
reason like I want I wish more people
more women and men would see oh I want
to have a healthy family I want to break
the generational trial the generational
this disrupt you know the generational
problems do you ever wish you stayed
absolutely really yeah well I wish we
could have worked it out absolutely so
what made you guys get divorced if you
don't mind me asking well I I came to
him and I gave him the very clear
parameters I was like listen I figured
this is happening it's undeniable we
can't deny this is happening so let's
just save our marriage and save our life
we have a great life and so I said you
know I need these three things to happen
and not only did they not happen but it
got much much worse and then it got
dangerous then it got violent and then
it got scary and then I you know then I
just felt like I didn't have a choice
because things got so violent dangerous
and scary so it went directly because of
cheating
it started off that way because there's
just so much lies and deceiving can I
trust this person and then but I really
really wanted to to make it work I was
like why don't we we'll just have an
open marriage which I knew would
probably kill me inside but I was like
yeah I even offered it you know I was
like that's really really wanted it I
didn't give him a contract for a second
child I said you have to pay for the
chat like I just I really wanted the
marriage to stay together but I just got
scared so if it was just strictly
cheating do you think it would have
worked out then it would have been all
right no well I needed certain things to
change I needed some Securities that
weren't that weren't that weren't there
because I think always insecurities do
you mind saying or no well when I found
out that he was cheating I also looked
into like our life a little bit more
deeply and I realized that absolutely
nothing was in my name okay I had
nothing and I was like oh my gosh I'm in
a really vulnerable position here
because I never even thought about it
and so then
I was like listen I need to have some
stake in our lives and it was a protect
protective mechanism clearly
um and he was like no
no way can I ask a question so did you
did you put yourself in that situation
where you wanted to make it work because
for Penelope for sure only all because
you loved him so did also I still love
him today and he's watching right now I
mean I was hoping he would come to
London yesterday and have lunch with us
is he still single yeah
would you ever get back with him
if I mean I would consider Penelope
thinks I'm crazy but I talk about it all
the time my dad would never get back
with her so it's like I don't I I don't
know
right now on camera no no don't do that
but can I ask a question but why
wouldn't you I know you said you would
you would you're doing it for Penelope
and I understand that absolutely you can
do anything to keep
um I think people will do anything
um for their children but
don't you think that you should love
yourself more instead of after what he's
done and I feel like you can do you
deserve better and you don't deserve to
be treated like glorified what being a
single parent was going to look like and
it was crazy because I had a single mom
so I should have known better but
honestly I think it's modern day child
abuse it is and I watched her and I
watched her in my I watched her growing
up struggle so much as one person to do
all the work at home like just one
person no support I mean it was so hard
for you like you were I remember the
nights you were like crying and it also
struck a a strong heart in my and for me
that was like I never want to have that
and I will do any anything and
everything my power to never create that
for my future family because that is so
it was so painful I don't wish that pain
on anything yeah
yeah because if I have a family I made a
I make a vow I make a vow I make a vow
to to God to higher power that I will
stick with this person for the rest of
my life of course I thought that I did
that with your father too but you know
it happened but I can never make up for
that for you not having a dad and there
was a spiritual disc like there was a
spiritual disconnection there
well our values were different I thought
we were an monogamous relationship but I
you know found out otherwise and uh
maybe it was a phase I don't know maybe
you can't change people I don't know but
you know it's sad I mean guys he still
admits this day he regrets what he did
he wished he didn't do what he did and
he and he and he wishes he could have
changed certain things so he's not like
doesn't have any remarks I just feel
like
majority no majority of men do at some
point in their life will cheat
in a relationship they will and if every
woman leaves a man for cheating then and
you have all these you know motherless
and fatherless family but I think I
think that's the thing we're never like
we're never as women we're never told
like how men are naturally and like men
just want to screw everything so it's
like we've kind of been told that if we
get cheated on it's the worst thing ever
and it can't be worked through that
because and the man isn't in the house
there's a lot of fatherlessness yeah I
think that most of I think that most of
society's problem really like come back
to single mother homes to be honest like
if you look at the prison population
it's like 80 single mother homes if you
look at
um youth suicides we are way more likely
to be abused as a child um you're way
more like every Big um I I spoke to a
homeless um shelter director down the
street and I said why why like are these
people homeless like because he has like
the worst type of homeless which is like
the street sleepers because there's
different like levels of people living
in cars there's whatever and he told me
that um he that most of these people
came from single mother homes especially
with like multiple baby daddies or like
whatever and they the kids I got ended
up getting taken and like put in the
system and they've never they don't know
any sense of stability or function
um and so if you look at all the like
major issues in society a lot are linked
to single mother homes and single father
homes don't have the same outcomes it's
not as bad but if you're seeing a lot of
if you grow up in a single household
when you see a breakup then in your head
it might seem like like you were saying
with your you can you can do this
because your mom will grow up in a
single home run so you might see it as I
this is something it's not easy but it's
something I can do and then when only
when you go through it you realize that
right this is mad but if we have a lot
more family units in the house and
working at things then the children get
to see like okay my mom and dad went
through this but they managed to go
through this route to to help and
because I've been through my in a
relationship where I've gone therapy and
I've gone places to to fix things you
get on Zan and even when you talk about
therapy earlier I don't think therapy is
there to fix things it's just there to
for you to it is I hope not not I don't
think therapy's there to fix I think
it's there to help you understand
triggers and understand certain things
for you to maneuver it can never therapy
can never fix nothing
honestly to be very honest with you
after going to therapy for eight years
maybe 12 yeah I don't believe in therapy
there are other ways to fix your
problems and you can also just really
get over yourself honestly I just
decided to get over myself and that's
basically how I feel well I think I
think that therapy like it's Outsourcing
families because like usually you would
go to your siblings or you go to because
your your mother is going to have a
completely different take like if you're
let's say if you're in an argument with
your boyfriend she's gonna have a
completely different take on the
situation because she knows you you and
she knows you're positive and you're
negative traits so it's like if I tell
my mom like oh this person reacted to me
this way mom's gonna be like well
people are scared of that real truth no
I just think that the therapist doesn't
have that information they didn't grow
up with you but like you who knows your
daughter better than you but that's what
I'm saying she might be she might be
scared to go to her mom because she's
gonna get that harsh reality and
sometimes people don't want the harsh
reality you know what I'm saying no I
love it that's she raised me that way
though yeah like the way you're the way
people raise their children dictates
also relationships how people reacting
so she raised me giving me the hard
truth since I was little and I hated it
I mean I would scream at you and cry I I
used to hate her but that's what I'm
saying you hate no one likes it you know
I used to hate her but now I love her
and I give her like all the props to be
honest with me when I didn't want to
hear it yeah she told me I was fat she's
like Penelope you need to get up and go
work out like she reminded me of that
every day that's good that's so funny I
used to get mad at Mama I wasn't I
wasn't that big but I was like that
pretty pretty chunky and my mom would
always be like on me because I was just
this die-hard like tomboy and I just
didn't want to like look not and I still
struggle with it to this David I'm like
oh my God I would be so much worse if my
mom wasn't like on me all the time
because when you're a kid you're just
like Mom like I don't wanna know her and
she's like this she has her master's
nutrition she's trained thousands of
people yeah I'm like I don't want you to
tell me what to eat like I don't want
you to tell me how to live how to work
out but I would sit in my room like
obese fat you know crying I was
depressed in my dark room all day and
she'd be like open the curtains rip the
curtains open be like
I bet if you're not gonna open now you
know I'm gonna take your phone away and
I was like it was like really intense
you know those are the kind of parents
that you need but I needed that because
this world is cruel and I've been
through some bad things and and having
that her mentality that she raised me
with being honest and saying penalty you
need to get up nope and I'll be this is
not true you know men there are men and
women like these are important things
that she taught me it's kind of funny
like the day you realize your parents
were right about everything like it's
like it's like you just wake up one day
and you're like
it was like around 21 or 22 for me I was
like oh my gosh my mom and dad raised me
so well and they were right about
everything they told me
we never listened through our teenager
Yes except for relationships oh yeah I'm
not listening to them for relationships
compared to those two
do you like the guy she's dating very
much yeah I mean I think that I think
that mothers like actually we should ask
our parents about those like people we
date yeah and I actually he met my mom
and my dad and I I would I wouldn't have
been with him if they didn't like him
yeah period because that's just how
that's just how it should be but man
like that as well because even the girl
I'm seeing now her family unit is strong
and I feel like it wouldn't have worked
if if her mama or things didn't
Enlightenment you know what I'm saying
totally and my family is like my most
important thing but my respect that once
the family is important to you totally
I'm close to you like I feel like I feel
like men respect women more when they
have that family Dynamic whoever the
even if the dad's not there if the dad's
day obviously he's going to respect it a
lot more in it because he's going to
come differently but if if he knows you
have a strong support unit with Mom
cousins aunties whatever yeah he is
going to respect you a lot more than if
a girl doesn't really have the same kind
of support we're asking how you find a
good woman and I I also find it really
challenging to know when you find a good
man I mean I think by now at 47 you know
it's challenging to find a good man I
think I found one whose values a line
but it's not that easy it's not easy
exactly what do you guys think how do
you know when a guy is a good guy
you know you can tell when the a man is
in line when he has a good woman
a good woman makes a good man no but
he's not good on his own first
okay
please stop please stop now I asked you
guys for her she's a single woman or
sort of she's dating someone but like
for a single woman how do you know if
it's a good man what do you think do you
think it's easy to tell as a guy who the
guy the good guys are
um no it's not easy it's not if he's
willing to accept your trauma he's a
good guy hmm that's a good one that's a
good one definitely because really
that's a good point yes that's a good
point
he supports you through
certain things you're going through and
Trauma that then you know like he
listens to your problems not not no just
not just listening forget the listening
okay he's actually there like raw like
cool you've gone let's say all right
what kind of example can I do maybe
working or not trying to work around you
in a way whatever the issue may be or
whatever it is going through yeah like
if she needs time like you're there but
your your support everybody
fundamentally I think that all most guys
a good guy
you know good guys we are good guys yeah
yeah I agree no um but the thing is it's
about have we found the right woman okay
so if we were with the right woman then
it works if we're not that it's not but
how does she see it though and she's not
going to see it but
um easily because it depends on who she
is all right this is what I just said to
Pearl it's about the woman but she
doesn't understand do you see me saying
it from a man like
in order for a man to be a good man you
have to have a good woman because the
woman will put you in line like man on
their own don't put themselves in line
we do reckless things we buy we spend
money recklessly we live recklessly
until you get that good one I was
chatting to remind them today in the
what's that group and it's like well you
could even remember was saying about a
man dressing well you could tell when a
man's dressing a certain way in a
relationship and out of a relationship
you can tell obviously I don't know
Magnum guitar I don't know if women can
tell but really the most like Dependable
like responsible man I know don't really
need a woman to like look after them not
to be honest it's not about need it's
about guidance so like I mean did you
get what I'm saying no because I'm just
thinking about the men like I respect
the most in my life that I really like
doing stuff um like I think of my dad
some of my brothers they don't need a
woman to like guide them or take care of
them they kind of have a path stuff they
want to do they don't really no we're
always going to have a part of it but
women have certain like we're practical
so we're always on your we need to do
this we need to do that when blah blah
where women are more
structured they will put their men are
structured but we will got we will see
we'll have a vision and we go for that
vision and sometimes we just go
because we can see what we're going for
we know we we got the picture in our
head but a woman a woman can organize
the route a bit better than a man can
organize them I think what you're saying
is more like enhancing your qualities
enhancing your life yeah maybe yeah but
like honestly for me I think that if if
a guy can get up even when he's sad when
he has a bad day maybe if he likes to
work out he'll do a workout go to work
not be emotional all the time you know
these things that if you already do them
without a woman that's good yeah we do
that naturally but yeah I know you he
was um
it's just this just sounds to me yeah
like the guys you don't want to date
which is the guys that like need a woman
yeah to like to guide them yeah yeah
like I would think you'd want like a
leader or maybe I'm wrong no no man's a
leader yeah
Disney organized man's paperwork
[Music]
you're kind of switching what you
started saying no I hate no but I'm okay
it's hard for me to explain it because
it's like
it's mad because obviously man I'm I'm
when I'm saying I'm focused man you can
be focused on something but sometimes
you need somebody there to help you in
line certain things because man we will
just do things like for example are you
shopping for example yeah
[Music]
I know exactly what I want I know what
I'm going there for I'm not spending
longer a woman will if they want a dress
or something or they want to choose you
try it on it's got to make sure it looks
right blah blah update oh they will
pattern up things make sure everything's
correct before they leave that do you
get what I'm saying about how does
somebody get in your size eight better
your Earth was better someone is getting
my Air Force better so is that because
she organizes your route
yeah but I'm just saying they will look
for more okay I'm gonna Read Super Chat
um okay guys make sure you like the
video did we open the chat do we get 2
000 likes blessing
yeah 1.2 oh 1.2 good job guys uh aw
message deleted I don't know what you
said but someone deleted it um Hiroshima
a 21st century uh is the biggest L For
Humanity we trusted women to be
accountable like men are but all they
did was Destroy Society roman-powered
women it's gone now is that true did
Rome do that
um Vincent Fraga the traditional
righteous focused um men focused since
youth to be Godly protectors providers
and intelligent for the purpose to build
families at large I'm Hiroshima average
Japanese guys doesn't leave his house
all I saw outside were Chad's and
good-looking guys they openly said they
had multiple girlfriends because that's
all they had the rest of the guys aren't
even in the dating pool just rotting at
home
um that was for the Japanese Super Chat
earlier
um Boy Thanks for the hard work pro
peace Gore I'm just being submissive
mean submit to your men are being or
doesn't mean submit to your family until
hats to stop talking away haha you're
right Zoro slot only simps want to wait
months if women isn't a virgin it's a
woman's job to retain a man after
hooking up uh
women want quality and men want quantity
we are not the same
um
what do you guys think about the phrase
I'm a woman that makes you wait for sex
isn't worth the wait
that's only true if you're that's only
true if you're not if she's not a real
version which I know you can't really
you know just you can't really tell but
that's that's what I think at least I
think you guys have to be mindful when
it comes to sex it's not just sex it's a
spiritual energy exchange I don't care
you guys I have to say this stuff like
like honestly it's not it's a big thing
so do you really want to just be having
sex with anyone and letting any kind of
energy into your energy like it's not
worth it is it I don't think it's worth
it and that's can I just say that for us
it is always a spiritual exchange for
them it might just be sex and you might
be thinking oh this is a spiritual
exchange but it's not and that's why I
probably only date spiritual men now now
at this point like I think if you
thought it was a spiritual exchange you
would have waited till you were married
this is what I mean like why like like
men hear the things we say and it
doesn't match up with what we do because
it's like okay you're 32 you've been
dating since you're 18. was every guy
you slept with in the last 12 years a
spiritual since 28 because I only
started spiritual enough 28 so my
mindset is completely true do you
realize there's like a pattern wait wait
so there's like a pattern so this is
this is like guys when they've dated
enough women they start to see like
patterns in our behavior and like one
thing that they found was like women
tend to like find God around the age of
28 so they kind of like start to Rebrand
so basically like like basically it's
kind of like a red flag when you say
around 28 I like found God or found the
spiritual journey because it's kind of
like okay I spent the first half of my
20s being a hoe and then now I'm not I'm
not saying a hoe but like okay how what
is a hoe statistically more than five
Partners okay so okay I look I don't I
don't need to know I don't know but but
what I'm saying like so a lot of times
like women sort of try to Rebrand it
just doesn't really seem like genuine
it's not really rebranding its growth
like
but this is this isn't this isn't the
men for me I'm telling you this is how
like men see it where it's like before
the men
um I gave this away for free now you pay
a premium price and so what that says to
the men is you're not genuinely
attracted to them because you were
genuinely attracted to the first guy
because you had sex with him right away
but you're not that attracted to the
second because you're making him wait
and bro I would even I would even say
that like you're like again going back
to like your body's a temple it's not
even just like your body's Temple it's
also like what food you eat you know how
you treat your body like are you working
out like are you taking care of yourself
like these things are part of that and I
think if you're doing all of those
things then yeah that both people should
wait because that means you're actually
you love yourself in a in an authentic
truthful way and you actually care about
your body and your beliefs so that
that's to me that would show that oh
what would show like eating right eating
right taking care of your body and also
not like having a bunch of tattoos and
not and not sleeping with a bunch of
people oh okay I see I see so being pure
being you know yeah so do you think that
um majority of men think that let's say
for example before you're 28 you've
slept around and then after 28 you found
God reborn again no I think that's
terrible that's just like that's just
like a cover-up
who's that though huh who who like is
that I don't think everyone's like that
but not everyone's like that I'm saying
but I mean they say there's a boon again
not at 28 yeah hold on I'm gonna read
this
I mean let's give them credit some of
them could be you can like you can find
God at the end of the day okay okay this
is this is this is from the rational
mail
um I previously described this phase as
parallels
um all right this this time the Epiphany
phase this is a precarious time for
women usually between the ages of 28 and
30 where she attempts to reassess the
last decade of her life women's um
psychological rationalization engine
begins a furious effort to account for
and explain her reasonings for not
having successfully secured a long-term
monogamous commitment from an alpha a
man a man her attractiveness could
attain for her even women married prior
to this phase will go through some
self-doubt or self-pity dealing with the
on or the hyper hypergamic uncertainty
of her choice is this really the best I
can do it is during this phase that
women will make radical shifts in their
proprietorization of what traits qualify
as attractive in a man an attempt to
turn over a new Leaf by changing up
their behaviors to allowing to with this
new persona they created themselves for
themselves since the physicality sexual
prowess and the alpha dominance that
made her formal arousal it's like so
more looks a formal arousal cues in men
aren't as forthcoming from men when she
was in her sexual prime she
reprioritizes them with preferences for
more intrinsic male attributes that
stress dependability provisioning
capacity humor intellect and um
esoteric definitions of compatibility
and intimacy for the spiritually
inclined women this may manifest in a
convenient return to the convictions she
disregarded since her adolescence for
others it may be a forced celibacy a
refusal to have sex under the hype
hypergamic why do you use these big
words awesome peas of her party years in
hopes that a well-provisioning male will
appreciate her for her Prudence so
unlike herself and all the other girls
who rejected him the last decade
so it's essentially like a Rebrand yeah
exactly but it said even for married
women it said right no that had been
married oh actually maybe wait let me
rewrite because I I understood it as
even married women go through some sort
of shift
you might be right you might be right
I'm just trying to find it
I understood that too and I think I
experienced that as well I didn't
divorce until I was 34 but I think that
goes back to like emotions how like
women act out of emotions and like I
feel like women need to find better ways
to deal with their emotions they're
usually stuffing them down that's why
there's so much obesity I know or
smearing them out like pushing them out
uh on smearing them other people through
projection it's pretty destructive so I
was like oh that's fine and you can just
be born again you can just
what who taught us who taught us how to
deal with our emotions or maybe our
parents didn't it's a natural thing no
it's not well I think women naturally
are emotional
no but we
we don't know we don't have to do it but
you're naturally emotional and it's that
so whatever you don't have to deal with
it don't always say who taught us it's
almost like a way for women like for us
to like get
in our language we like take
accountability off of women where it's
like we blame our choices over who
taught us where it's like if a guy's in
jail they don't say who taught you that
they just say you never notice that for
sure no absolutely like I don't think
it's like intentional I just think I
feel like there's like these little
things in conversation where we like
take accountability off of women and
like put it on to someone else yeah
thanks for Shining Light on that it's
our responsibility
yeah definitely
um okay
um I I think I'm gonna Read Super chats
one more time
but let me actually I want to go back
really quick
oh can I add something to the list
before I forget sorry sorry
if because you were talking about a good
woman I think yeah if she how she deals
with past mistakes so this is part
accountability part admitting to them
and as I appreciate her because she said
I Grew From that and I made better
choices so how did she did she change
her behavior exactly so that's the third
component does your behavior changed
maybe if she if he tells her something
does it change
you know I mean like if he says like
you're argumentative does it switch or
does she do the same thing yeah yeah
yeah if he says get out of my house does
she leave or stay
um it's three months of seeing ask her
to make him a coffee ask her to cook on
the spot take her guys we could have did
a better list
I think we could have improved this it's
okay you know no no hate but I am hating
on the list a little bit take a coffee
date date as many women as possible to
tell the difference make sure she's not
on birth control what is her
relationship like with her family and
her dad how does she deal with past
mistakes
um yeah all those things just being open
and honest as well is she open and
honest
difficult situations because you could
talk to a woman oh sorry I didn't write
that down earlier yeah you could talk to
a woman and tell whether she's being old
like if she's telling you things while
she's doing things throughout a day or
she's meeting friends or whatever if
she's openly communicating with you on a
regular basis I think that's that's a
healthy part of the relationship
together I'm saying what do you mean by
openly
like just talking to you about things
like everything she's doing she's just
telling you openly and honestly like
y'all
cool let's say she's met up with friends
oh I've done this and and then she might
talk about the conversation that they
had I don't think my man would be
interested to be honest
the most interesting I might take up too
much of the day that's right
[Music]
I'm curious what model like did you do
you have like are you basing this off of
what am I doing no I'm just curious is
there like a relationship model like
someone in your life I feel like the the
person I've met now we have a strong
connection and and bond and openness in
our relationship no I mean like growing
up is that what you saw we're all
growing up growing up well as in what do
you mean open in relationship I don't
know yeah like it's just like the way
you speak about relationships just
doesn't match up with like what I've
seen
um in successful relationships so I'm
just wondering like where relationships
so I can't say that I've had a
successful relationship I didn't know if
your parents or your your grandparents
or what my grandparents are still
married okay and they're in the
Caribbean so I do have that my my direct
parents or not but I think Me growing up
that list of what you're saying about
going through a lot of people I went
through to my teenage age 20 years of
not doing a lot of things with girls but
I changed a lot of girls regular so I
have a lot of understanding of women and
I've dealt with a lot of women okay
talking bases not just sleeping with
whatever yeah because I'm just I've just
found that like men typically don't want
to really hear about our problems like
that but we don't know I'm not talking
I'm not saying I want to hear your
problems I'm just saying your day to an
extent not not things about your friends
and all that stuff but about if it's
about you of course yeah I mean I I
think but I think they want to like
problems that they can solve but not
just yeah 100 but that's part of the
openness and honest of the conversation
if you come into me with certain things
then I can see how I can help you
maneuver that certain situation to the
pretty wait for the pretty lady in the
black dress if your ex don't want you I
will have you come on
I feel like if you're negative if if
you're negative to your partner that's a
negative thing like I think you should
not I think you should only bring
positive to the situation and there's a
difference between being like Oh my gosh
this thing happened to me this thing
happened to me then being like Oh hey I
had this situation how do you how would
you work it out or how should I work it
out that's so different and that's like
also maturity so I think you have to
always be positive and always have a
positive outlook on life because if
you're bringing negativity to anyone
they're going to want to distance
themselves from you I think that's
important some people because there's a
lot of toxic relationships
there's a direct correlation between
these men's posture and their lists they
submitted coffee is good typically three
months typically is wild to wait I wish
they would quit keep stop or they would
stop beating around the bush
bring back sneako
um okay I think I'm gonna we're gonna do
final thoughts I know you guys have been
here forever
um
the guys
um let me just make sure there's no
other Super Shots that we do
you know
I think we need to work on the list next
time
you guys come back
but it's all right it's all right the
things you should said that's a sick I
love that list that is amazing honestly
that is the ideal it's collaborative if
anyone I just build these throughout
shows if anyone's got you know if that
person wants to write back what's the
comparison from our Prosper to what
we're saying what you were saying about
the posture I think what we're comparing
to our list
back with that one okay yeah if you
wanted the posture guy if you want to
clarify what you meant um feel free to
put it in the chat
um
uh and their list they submitted there's
a direct correlation between their
posture and the list they submitted yeah
well no because I've been feeling like
listen I want to know what my process is
saying on the camera can't see I I think
it's like um I think it's not good I
think
um I think
yeah
it's not the most like professional
posture and I feel bad saying this
because I don't always have the best
posture no no I get it you know you know
it is yeah okay
um too comfortable I'm too comfortable
in it you know I I don't put words into
my mouth but I think that you could say
how you feeling you know I don't know if
I don't have a strong opinion on posture
you know bring back top G we love your
content
overwhelmingly it happens in your show
the women's State they know what men
want and discount everything the men say
when they disagree
Alex there's a direct correlation
between the oh that's the other one Alex
all right we'll do final thoughts and
we'll see if Alex you know sends another
or blessing watch the chat see if he
clarifies uh but thank you guys for
coming uh this was a fun show I
especially enjoyed the 300 pound story
you know I thought that was especially
great because I think that these whales
are lying to you guys don't let them
nobody's happy being obese all right
were you happy I was not happy I was
miserable I wanted to kill myself I
wanted to die I was Terr I lost all my
friends I was miserable locked up in my
dark room for two years and I I just
lived a miserable life and and the and
media lied to me this the body
positivity movement lied to you and
don't let them lie to you because they
will and I just ask you to reject that
movement and create your own which is
solve your own problem get out of bed
move your body every day eat healthy
food and if you need help you know we
have the Step It Up program that we
created that's doing a beta launch in
July and if you want to learn more you
know you can go to step it up Instagram
and the links in BIO cool cool you guys
flew to come out here right we did yeah
yesterday morning it's like wow that's
impressive
um okay um give your final thoughts
everyone and then this row and then
second row go ahead well I'm just so
grateful to be here thank you for having
us yeah thanks for coming I love this
conversation it was a challenging
conversation for me also confronting had
me think about a few things which was
surprising to me I appreciate it
um I feel like the body positivity
movement and Penelope's success has
really shed some light on what we have
to do
um it's true that I was a plus size
model I've struggled with it my whole
life my first Weight Watchers meeting
was at age five
and I've been you know trying every diet
in the world and it's not about a diet
it's about a lifestyle and it's about
you know food Fitness and mindset the
three pillars that make a difference and
I'm just so honored that Penelope's on
this journey with me yeah here in this
room but also like in this in this
business because we've got to help and
we know how and we're not perfect we're
on our journey too and uh so step it UPS
is where you find us and join us to
learn more get some delicious recipes
make it a fun and abundant and forever
amazing well thank you for having me as
well and thank you all for sharing your
views and your perspectives and
relationships I I just want to end with
saying that I think nobody's perfect
like we're all on a journey as well but
I do believe now at this age that
spirituality will solve everyone's
problems like it's just much more
cleaner it's more High vibrational it's
more positive and it can lead to better
results in relationships in any type of
relationship family
um partners and I just think when you
work on yourself and you try your best
and you and you you know you continually
grow then it will it will show that's
what you receive in life and that's what
you know you attract positive
relationships happy people and feeling
more fulfilled so thank you I think
spirituality is when women want to seem
religious and do nothing
I think religion is great I think
religion is great trying to be separate
what I think religion and spirituality
is two different things I think I think
that spirituality is like lazy religion
gee things yeah yeah I think it's a lot
of like women that like don't want to do
anything and they want to like the title
of being religious without actively
attending church
or living according to the Bible oh okay
that's religion not sexualities but I'm
not a Christian or any any religion I
know so because you're spiritual yeah
yeah
it's more it's more about believing in
the universe and having like positive
affirmations and trying to you know have
a schedule and just improve your overall
self and work on yourself and all that
kind of stuff thank you confirm for
confirming exactly what I just said
right because religious people have to
do things and spiritual people just
affirm and it's all about the mind
that's what it's about right they think
really hard it's a deep thing a deep
process yeah yeah it is very different I
do I do I do like you know you're a good
sport you're a good sport thank you for
coming go ahead
um I just want to say thank you Pearl
for having us on it's been so amazing to
have these conversations here um I think
these conversations also change people's
lives um and I just I value that I value
what you're doing I think it's a very
amazing movement
um and I also want to say like for
anyone watching out there any young
women and men I used to be in I used to
be 300 pounds right I used to be in your
position and I know how it feels I know
you think there's no no solve for this
problem I know you think there's no diet
that's going to work I know you think
all these things and and you can keep
believing social media if you want to
but then you will stay miserable forever
and so I'm just I just want to be that
little Sparkle in your life that little
angel on your shoulder that's like hey
you can do it and we're here to help you
like we have the answers and solutions
that have worked for us because her my
mom's grandmother died I mean my
grandmother died and I almost died and
my mom if she could she would have had
me if she lost her life to obesity um
when she was young so I just want to say
like we have the answers go to step it
UPS on Instagram you can watch us in the
7Up podcast as well
um and we're here for you
thank you very much Pearl for having me
tonight and this was a very uh great
conversation it was great to hear uh
people's thought and I want to give a
special credit to this amazing mother
and daughter relationship here there are
bringing value and spreading a message
because yes obesity is not the key and
the society should uh wake up to this
call and just function from a healthy
mindset and like body and mind and
spirit I do I believe in spirituality to
an extent as well but I believe that
it's uh it's a correlation between other
components as well that might even
include the the mindset and the
nutrition that could create a balance
and it was good to hear the man as well
Express how they might think of a
perfect woman or a good woman is so yeah
that was a great uh episode tonight
thank you
yes spell big up yourself for having us
on your platform appreciate everyone
that shared their past and traumas
regarding the Good Woman and bad good
woman good man
don't complicate it too much just ask
the man
what he wants yeah
well done yeah man oh I got an answer
for your posture
all right don't don't say I never give
solutions to someone all right posture
as a male is important slouching is
passive I think it's men we need to do
better and maintain great posture Justin
Waller was an example or for example was
just on and maintained great Pastor role
model I've actually I've been so
impressed with your posture the whole
time I'm like this girl sits straight up
but yeah that's what they said I know
you know it is
be got yourself pill thanks for having
us on obviously we do a podcast
ourselves DMD podcast if you want to
check us out website dmdlive.co.uk
um so maybe that's why my posture is a
bit bad because we've been doing this
for about six seven years it's too
comfortable in the chair and it's very
relaxing
um obviously
appreciate everyone for saying their
views you know it it was kind of a
eye-opener for myself as well because
obviously with the all the stats that he
was bringing out no I'm not really I'm
not really a stats person so knowing all
of that and the obviously and stuff like
that it has opened my mind but
curvy girls still do your thing stay
healthy but be curvy you get me
um and yeah I got another podcast as
well with tricky big Jess called live
and live and direct so yeah man check us
out
a second
oh me okay
um yeah I mean I think in terms of the
question uh we really got there it
quite near the start when we're talking
about
um having had having experience so for
men to have experience of women is
probably the best way of knowing uh what
what you're looking at and it really is
a case of
um you know when you see it so you knew
it you know a good girl if you see her
and also vice versa
um but yeah and again uh inspiring story
uh with weight loss
um you know having obesity behind you
literally I'm sat behind you
um and uh yeah something I need to
follow and look into
um yeah thank you so much for having me
I also want to say I'm so glad to have
met you all uh and really nice to to be
here uh just a couple of things I think
the first topic was how do you find a
good woman and a good man I really enjoy
hearing from you obviously because
there's always something to learn
um and I think it's great to have these
conversations but at the end of the day
um when we are in our natural roles as
we were supposed to be this is the
perfect way to know and unfortunately
society around us is so messed up at the
moment that um not ever it's really hard
to stay there so on top of that I just
want to say for all the women out there
who still have to work I come from a
family where my mother was working my
grandma was working uh it's I don't want
to bring them down you know I feel like
just this part was a bit negative around
okay what if you can't afford to be a
housewife what if you are in the
workforce it is possible my family and
the background that I come from the
women did their jobs but came home and
they were still feminine so I had the I
think I had the best example it's really
hard and I think we were lied to when
people say to us marriage is supposed to
be easy it's not an easy thing you know
they just
you're not happy every day but you just
stick it out and you love the other
person so it's not an easy ride as far
as I'm told so
um yeah again thank you so much
okay Avon totter um thank you for the
Super Chat uh Nas says bring back top G
um we love your content bro he's on
house arrest so you know off the table
for now but in the future he's always
welcome okay guys
um make sure you like the video
I read it oh I read it earlier the
slouching is passive don't Gaslight me
uh a lot of gaslighting here um okay
okay are we gonna announce what's coming
up after I mean what's coming up oh the
video
oh yeah you know there's been some
recent critics
some recent critics that you know push a
false narrative fake news TMZ of YouTube
making up stories about your girl pearl
putting clip clip clip together spinning
a narrative fake news blah blah blah
um yeah so don't worry we'll have a
response that's coming up probably next
how soon I don't know that we're gonna
film it after this show you know it's
like some people are busy filming
original content and other people are
sitting there reacting to it so um
anyways guys like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel
um first tier you already know you get
to be a part of the chat um sign up for
the fourth tier you get to one-on-one
call with me once a month uh subscribe
to wife school like the video on your
way out um subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you guys next time
but
you've changed it on yourself he's
chatting [__] no nobody it's a red what
up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's Village Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of is
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men I'm not
saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
okay okay then then get out then get out
faster Esther then get out I'm not here
to get canceled today most men want a
woman that has some degree of femininity
where they feel like they're taking care
of taking care of lady like I'm
submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened in society that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag now he's
thank you